Rồi ok các bạn hôm nay là buổi khai
giảng của lớp data machining số 21. Số
21 thì cái số của lớp chúng ta cũng
chính là số khóa mình đã từng dạy lớp
này. Ờ lớp đầu tiên mình dạy vào cuối
2022 cho nay thì mình đã dậy được khoảng
3 năm rư rồi. Ờ buổi này là buổi khai
giảng. Buổi này là buổi khai giảng thì
mình muốn dành ra khoảng 10 cho đến 15
phút đầu tiên để à để lớp chúng ta có
thể giới thiệu qua một chút về bản thân.
Tại vì chúng ta là lớp học online, chúng
ta không có dịp để chúng ta có thể gặp
nhau ở ngoài đời thực như là những lớp
học offline bình thường. Nên mình rất là
muốn là chúng ta có thể dành phút thời
gian của buổi đầu để chúng ta có cơ hội
chúng ta giới thiệu về bản thân và chúng
ta cũng đồng thời chúng ta sẽ có thể
biết được là các cái bạn học của mình có
cái nền tảng là gì, họ đến từ đâu hay là
họ có cái a nguyện vọng gì. Thế thì dới
hiệu qua một chút bản thân thì cũng
không cần phải quá là dài dòng hoặc là
cao siêu gì đâu. Các bạn chỉ nói giới
thiệu qua một chút là các bạn là ai, các
bạn đang học, các bạn đang công tác ở
đâu, các bạn có cái mục đích gì khi các
bạn tham gia khóa học này. Ờ các bạn có
thể chia sẻ chút về cái dị tương lai. Ví
dụ sau này các bạn sẽ muốn là các bạn đi
du học hay là các bạn à giá trường các
bạn đi làm luôn hoặc các bạn đang muốn
ứng dụng AI vào để các bạn giải quyết
những cái bài toán trong công ty là
trong doanh nghiệp của mình cũng được
đúng không? Th chỉ giới thiệu qua một
chút là như vậy thôi. Ừ mình giới thiệu
trước đi. Mình giới thiệu trước đi. Thì
mình chắc là các bạn vào đây các bạn
cũng đều biết mình là ai rồi các bạn mới
đăng ký đúng không? Như vậy mình xin
phép được giới thiệu lại qua một chút về
bản thân mình. Mình tên là Việt mình là
cựu sinh viên của đào học Bách Khoa Hà
Nội. À ngày xưa hội mình học Bách Khoa
thì mình học nhên khóa 2009 2014 mình
học về
ngành mình học về học về công nghệ thông
tin. Chuyên ngành của mình hồi đấy là về
truyền thông và mạng máy tính. 2014 mình
tốt nghiệp đó. Thì 2015 mình sang mình à
mình bắt đầu du học mình mới bắt đầu
trình học thạc sĩ tại à Đại học Kỹ thuật
Munich. Mình học đấy hết 2 năm rưỡ thì
2018 mình tốt nghiệp thì mình chuyển từ
Munich đến Berlin và mình sinh sống và
làm việc trập điệp ở Berlin cho đến tận
đầu năm ngoái mình đã trải qua các cái
vị trí như là data scientist, machining
engineer và hiện tại mình đang là senior
A engineer. Ờ hiện tại thì mình làm
remote cho công ty ở Đức và mình đồng
thời mình là đảng viên của khoa cơm tin
tại Đại học Kinh tế Quốc dân. Ờ cuối
tuần thì mình mở những mở những cái lớp
học online để mình có thể
chia sẻ những cái kiến thức ờ kinh
nghiệm về AI, về machining, về data về
mình đã tích lũy được trong 10 năm qua.
Tất nhiên với các bạn là chia sẻ kiến
thức, còn với mình là kiếm tiền rồi đúng
không? Thế thì mình đã như mình nói ở
đầu thì mình đã dạy học được khoảng 3
năm rưỡi rồi. Thế mình rất là hy vọng là
những cái khóa học này của mình sẽ cung
cấp cho bạn những cái kiến thức hữu ích
để sau này các bạn có thể các bạn đi làm
hoặc là các bạn có thể áp dụng những
kiến thức đã học vào trong công việc của
mình. Thì đây là một vài lời về bản thân
mình. Nào phần mình xong rồi đến các bạn
đi. Lớp chúng ta thì cũng thoải mái
thôi. Các bạn không cần phải giơ tay
đâu. Thế không ai nói gì các bạn cứ bật
nick các bạn nói thôi. Có bạn nào các
bạn có thể sẵn lòng các bạn chia sẻ một
chút về bản thân mình được không?
Có bạn nào không nhỉ?
Anyone?
>> Em chào anh ạ.
>> À h ok chào em.
>> Em hình như có một bạn cũng đang định
nói sao?
>> Ô sao em cứ nói luôn đi. Em cũng đã nói
rồi. Bạn đã nói sau.
>> Vâng. Ừ. Em chào anh các bạn. Không biết
là ở đây chắc cũng có nhiều người em
không biết nên đây cứ chào bạn.
>> À chào bạn đi.
>> Ờ không không ý là với các bạn khác anh
thì chắc chắn là hơn tuổi em rồi. Tại vì
em cũng học mới khoai. À h
>> và em a học em là K62 bách khoa nhưng mà
chuyên ngành của em là tự động hóa cơ
>> à. Ok. Tự động hóa [hắng giọng] là là tự
động hóa là của bên bên điện đúng không
nhỉ?
>> Đúng rồi. Đượ viên điện đúng vậy.
>> Ok.
>> Ờ vâng thì em học từ động hóa nhưng mà
lúc ra trường thì em lại à chuyển rẽ
nhánh sang Android
>> à.
>> Ở Samsung Việt Nam.
>> À h
>> dạ vâng. Thì em thấy dọo này thì công ty
em cũng bắt đầu cũng có xu hướng kiểu là
tích hợp AI và công việc các thứ. Ừ,
>> ví dụ như là A các thứ thì em cũng định
hướng là có thể là sau này mình sẽ theo
hướng làm A hoặc là làm những cái phát
triển về một số cái dự án về AI on
device.
>> Nói chung là em em nghĩ là chuyển hẳn
sang AI thì cũng hơi khó
>> với với hiện tại với tầm tuổi em bây giờ
nữa. Thì em sẽ nghĩ là hướng mà em theo
đuổi th là làm Android app nhưng mà tích
hợp theo AI.
>> Dạ. Dạ.
>> Dạ. Vâng.
>> Great. Ok. Đây bạn học từ độu khóa. Ờ
chia sẻ một tí cái thời ngày xưa của
mình. Cái thường ngày xưa thì tự động
khóa nó nó vẫn là viện hay là khoa nó
chưa lên à quên mất điện nó vẫn là viện
hay là khoa nó chưa lên trường. Nhưng
bây giờ ngày xưa
>> ừ
>> ngày xưa mình cái tự bên khoa cái tự độ
hào nó hay lắm các bạn ạ. Tức là cái
khoa mà chừa nó ấy là khoa điện ấy nó
không phải là khoa điểm cao nhất nhưng
mà cái ngành tự động hóa là cái ngành
điểm cao nhất của cả cái trường. Thế tức
là cái khoa đầu vào thì không cao nhưng
mà cái ngành đấy thì lại cao. Rất là
cao. Ok. Con em thì tự động hóa thì kém
sau mỗi IT
>> à. À bây giờ có thể IT nó nó lên ngôi
thường ngày thường ngày xưa nó khác.
>> Ok. Ok. K62 tức là thua mình 8 tuổi. Ok.
>> Dạ vậy.
>> Rồi ok. Rất là cảm ơn bạn. Đấy đúng
không? Có giới thiệu đơn giản như vậy
thôi. Nào có bạn nào nữa nào?
Có bạn nào nữa không?
Có bạn nào muốn giới thiệu chú à đang là
de Java đang làm cho có thể Ấn Độ đúng.
Ừ. Ok. T Java đang làm cho việc Ấn Độ
đến với lớp này muốn tìm hiểu bản chất
bên trong AI. Ok. Good great.
Có bạn nào sẵn lòng giới thiệu về bản
thân nữa không?
À mình 35 tuổi các bạn nhá. Nếu các bạn
muốn dễ dưng ngô mình 3 năm tuổi. Nếu mà
các bạn muốn dưng ngô mình mình 35 tuổi
cho bạn dễ nhá.
>> Ờ chào Việt à chào mọi người, chào các
bạn trong lớp mình. Mọi người nghe thấy
mình nói không nhỉ?
>> Dạ có ạ. Dạ có ạ.
>> Mình xin giới thiệu mình tên là Tùng.
mình cũng đang đi làm rồi cũng trong
công việc thì của mình cũng liên quan
một chút đến công nghệ thông tin nhưng
mà ờ không liên quan gì đến AI cả. Nhưng
mà cái
mình thấy hiện tại bây giờ
với cả ngay trong cái công ty mình làm
thì ứng dụng AI rất là nhiều rồi. trong
mọi cái quy trình sản xuất và trong ờ
nói chung trong rất nhiều cái nên mình
muốn học và để hiểu được bản chất ờ của
AI
để mình có thể ứng dụng được vào trong ờ
chính công việc của mình hoặc là hỗ trợ
cho công việc của mình.
>> Ờ đấy đấy mục tiêu của mình là như vậy.
>> Dạ dạ.
À vâng em cảm ơn anh
>> mình. Cái background background về AI
của mình thì bây giờ ờ nó cũng mới là
beginner thôi.
>> Mình mới tập làm quen với tất cả những
công cụ như là chat GPG Gemini hoặc là
những cái phổ thông bình thường và mọi
người phổ thông dùng. Đấy.
>> Đấy nó là như thế. Và mình cũng có tìm
hiểu một chút ít về những cái như là
Viber coding thôi.
>> Dạ.
>> Ờ nhưng mà những cái kiến thức quan
trọng về những cái căn bản sâu xa nhất
của AI thì mình vẫn phải cần học.
và nhận được sự chỉ bảo giúp đỡ của việc
và các bạn thì mình mới hiểu được bản
chất của vấn đề. Tại vì mình cảm thấy AI
nó không chỉ những cái mình làm quen mới
chỉ nó mình thấy nó chỉ là một cái bề
nổi của vấn đề thôi để cho người dùng
thôi. Mình muốn học chuyên sâu thêm để
mình ứng dụng công việc của mình. Đấy
mình mong là à trong thời gian tới thì
nhận được sự chuyển đạt của Việt và các
bạn. Cảm ơn.
>> Dạ vâng. Dạ vâng em cảm ơn anh ạ. Dạ
vâng em cảm ơn anh. Không một bạn tiếp
đi ạ. Không phải giơ tay đâu, mọi người
cứ nói thôi, chả phải giơ tay đâu.
Mình chưa nghe thấy gì cả. Hình như là
chọn nhầm mic rồi.
Mình vẫn chưa nghe thấy gì.
Và có thể một bạn nào khác nói trước
cũng được. T bạn ấy chỉnh được mic xong
thì nói sau. Sự viên tốt nghiệp công
nghệ thông tin trường đại học Cần Thơ
lập trình FPT Hà Nội à ok chu ngành AI à
ok
một bạn sinh viên năm nhất của FPT một
bạn là mới sinh viên mới tốt nghiệp của
Đại học Cần Thơ ok có bạn nào có thể có
bạn nào có mic các bạn có thể chia sẻ
một chút không ờ bạn nào không có mic
các bạn viết cũng được nhưng mà mình thì
rất là thích mình rất là muốn được nghe
các bạn rất là muốn được nghe các bạn
có bạn nào muốn giới th hiệu qua chút
bản thân nữa không
chào anh
>> em là Cường
>> à
>> em 33 tuổi
>> em thì đang làm trong cái lĩnh vực tin
sinh em làm giữa về ginomic thì đợt này
thì kiểu nó cũng nổi đổi với cái kiểu
ứng dụng AI machine learning rồi deep
learning các thứ vào thì em muốn học tìm
hiểu thêm để mà cho nó hiểu bản chất
thực ra em thấy tự học thì nó cũng hơi
hơi hơi hơi vất và khả năng là nên là em
a tìm đến cái lớp học như này thì kiểu
có thì em nghĩ là nó sẽ nhanh hơn cái
việc là mình tự tìm hiểu, mình tự học
ấy.
>> Dạ. Thì em muốn là xem là nó có ứng dụng
được gì vào cái cái mình đang làm không
và thực tế bây giờ nó ứng dụng rất là
nhiều đấy.
>> Dạ.
>> Nên là cũng phải học cho nó đỡ tụt hậu.
>> Dạ. Nhà ok cảm ơn em. Ok bạn ngoài đầu
cũng đầu ba giống như mình. Ok cảm ơn
em. Rồi có bạn nào nữa nhở?
Chào anh.
>> Ok. Phần nào cũng được. Phần nào cũng
được.
Xin phép mình nói trước nha bạn.
ạ. Dạ em chào anh và cũng như tất cả các
bạn các anh chị các bạn ở trong lớp học.
Dạ thì em tên là Đại Bảo. Thì hiện tại
em là sinh viên trao đổi nhân và trao
đổi du học du học tại Pháp.
>> Chuyên ngành của em là về kỹ thuật hàng
không.
>> Ừ.
Tức là hàng không. Ok. Ơ vì sao em lại
muốn học về à nhỉ?
>> À vâng.
hiện tại là về lúc trước khi em ở Việt
Nam thì chuyên ngành của em về khí động
lực học
>> nhưng mà khi mà em sang Pháp thì em đã
chuyển sang chuyên ngành về hệ thống
nhúng và
về data science
>> system đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi. Thì hiện tại sắp tới thì
vào tháng năm này thì em sẽ có công việc
thực tập liên quan đến sẽ ứng dụng về
học máy cũng như về data science là em
muốn học để tích kiến thức [tiếng cười]
để áp dụng vào tập của em.
>> Ok. Ok. Cảm ơn em. Pháp. Pháp cùng múi
giờ với Đức lệch 5 tiếng có nghĩa là bây
giờ là 1:11 chiều đúng không?
>> Dạ đúng rồi.
>> Ok. Ok. Great. Ok. Cảm ơn em. Ok. Cảm ơn
em. Ok. Ok. Bạn nào nữa nhở?
Có bạn nào muốn thế?
>> Ờ em chào anh Việt. Em chào mọi người.
>> Dạ.
>> À hiện tại em đang là sinh viên 53 của
trường Đại học Công nghệ thông tin của
Đại học Quốc gia Thành phố Hồ Chí Minh.
>> À thì chuyên ngành chính của em là
Computer Science.
>> Thì trong cái quá trình mà em đi học thì
những cái môn em học chủ yếu nó cũng sẽ
xoay quanh machine learning, deep
learning và một số những cái chủ đề
chính mà khoa em họ tập trung nghiên cứu
đó là về CV và NLB. À h thì em tham gia
khóa học này là em muốn mình có thể tổng
hợp được kiến thức tại vì em thấy là cái
ngành của em á cái ngành CS thì nó nó
khá là rộng. Em không chưa định hướng
được là em sẽ theo hướng CV hay là theo
hướng NLB.
>> Ừ.
>> Và mặc dù em học khoa CS [hắng giọng]
nhưng mà em cũng khá là thích data
science nhưng mà em lại không chuyển qua
khoa đó được.
>> À hả?
>> Mặc dù là học CS nhưng mà công việc hiện
tại của em lại là một data analyst.
>> Ừ. Nhưng mà em vẫn trong tương lai thì
em vẫn hy vọng là em có thể chuyển qua
AI engineer hoặc là chuyển qua data
engineer
>> nên là em cần phải có kiến thức về
>> data engineer hay là em muốn chuyển qua
data engineer hay là hay data scientist?
Em nghĩ là data scientist thì nó sẽ kiểu
cần nhiều kiến thức hơn so với lại data
engineer. Dat thì em thì em thực sự là
em cũng chả cần biết gì về AI thì em vẫn
thể đene được. Tại vì là em sử dụng SQL
em hơi phân vân giữa data engineer và AI
Engineer tại vì em thấy hiện tại ở cái
những cái bạn cùng lớp của em thì mọi
người đi thực tập về Aineer khá là
nhiều.
>> Đúng rồi. Cái đấy thì cần AI. A Engineer
thì cần AI đểu.
>> Dạ.
>> Ừ
>> nên là em phân vân giữ hai cái hướng đó.
>> Ok.
>> Dạ. Cảm ơn anh.
>> Ok. Cảm ơn em. Ok. Great. Ok. Có bạn nào
nữa không?
>> Dạ. Alo. À
>> ừ có nghe được em không?
>> Có nghe được. Nghe được.
>> Dạ em chào anh Việt và tất cả các bạn.
Em là một à software engineer. Hiện tại
em đang làm cho một công ty global ở
Việt Nam nhưng mà trủ sở nó là tục về
Mỹ.
>> Nó trụ sở này ở Việt Nam. Hả?
>> Hiện tại thì ngày xưa thì em học trường
Đại học Thành phố Hồ Chí Minh. Đại học
mở thành phố Hồ Chí Minh đây em là công
nghệ phần mềm.
>> Ừ.
>> Nhưng mà em đi làm thì em làm về hiện
tại hiện tại thì em làm về backend.
>> À h
>> nhưng mà ngày trước hồi trước đó thì em
có tìm hiểu qua N8N mà có cái kiểu như
em thuộc về automation là chính. À hả?
>> Nhưng mà giờ anh anh nhảy qua em làm về
back và web
>> app cho dạng như là làm về mấy cái apps
>> à hả?
>> H
>> em muốn học AI này để ứng dụng cái tích
hợp cái AI này vào cái website và cái
ứng dụng
>> à. Ok cảm ơn em. Ok cảm ơn em. Rồi ok
rất cảm ơn em. Ok bạn nào tiếp nào?
Có bạn nào muốn giới thiệu về bản thân
nữa không?
Ok thôi rồi. Thôi rồi. Ok không sao. Hi
vọng là trong quá trình học chúng ta sẽ
có thêm nhiều cơ hội để chúng ta có thể
giao đều cho để tương tác nữa.
Trước khi trước khi bắt đầu vào những
cái nội dung đầu tiên thì mình có một
vài lời mình muốn nói trước.
Cái khóa hot này được mình thiết kế dựa
trên chính là cái kinh nghiệm cũng như
là cái trải nghiệm của bản thân mình.
Mọi người đã học và làm trong level AI
được hơn 10 năm nay rồi. Và mình học
được AI từ cái thời mà AI nó chưa phổ
biến từ 2015 chứ không phải là AI nó hot
rồi mình mới học nhá. À thế mình không
phải là kiểu là mấy năm nay ai hot rồi
học vội học vàng rồi để dạy các bạn đâu.
Và thực sự là cái mảng này là cái mảng
mình đã theo suốt hơn chục năm nay rồi.
Ờ có một cái điểm mình muốn chia sẻ thế
này đó là ờ các bạn biết là ngày nay AI
rất là rất là phát triển, rất là phổ
biến đúng không? Rất nhiều người giống
như các bạn muốn học AI ờ
và cũng có rất nhiều người sợ là bây giờ
ai nhiều người học quá thì làm sao mình
có thể cạnh tranh được. Thế nhưng mà
trong cái quá trình mình đã tiếp xúc với
rất là nhiều người làm trong ngành cũng
như là những rất nhiều bạn có nhu cầu
học thì thì có có một vài điều mà mình
rút ra đó là ờ các bạn tin mình đi. Có
rất nhiều người người ta muốn học về AI.
Mình không nói các bạn nhá. Mình không
nói các bạn nhưng mà ý mình là có rất
nhiều người ta muốn học về AI tại vì là
người ta tò mò người ta thấy là à dùng
những công cụ AI như kiểu là chat GPT
Gaming Dipsic Load nó rất là hay như vậy
chắc hẳn là ai nó rất là thú vị mà người
ta muốn học thử thế và thấy nhiều khi là
cái tậ tâm lý phomo thôi đúng không
mình bị à
không theo kịp cái xu hướng mới. Có rất
nhiều người ta học rất nhiều người ta
muốn học ai là vì như vậy. Thế nhưng mà
có một cái điểm này đó là ờ dùng AI nó
sẽ là một cái trải nghiệm hoàn toàn so
với học AI. Khi các bạn dùng AI là các
bạn đang tiếp cận, các bạn đang sử dụng
AI dưới góc nhìn của user hay là người
dùng cuối. Nhưng mà khi các bạn học AI
và đặc biệt là cái học cái khóa học như
thế này là các bạn đang tiếp cận AI dưới
cái hướng là của những người người ta
xây dựng sản phẩm. Các bạn chú ý là cái
này ấ khi nó về AI khi nó về học AI ấ
cái khóa học về AI nó sẽ có nó sẽ có hai
nhóm chính. Một là nhóm những người học
AI theo hướng là sử dụng công cụ. Sử
dụng công cụ có nghĩa là gì? Tức là các
bạn có thể dùng các cái ờ các cái các
cái công cụ AI như kiểu chatbt, Gam,
Dipsic rồi ờ rồi Sora các thứ để các bạn
có thể ví dụ là các bạn dùng AI các cung
AI để các bạn tạo ra ảnh hoặc là video
để bán hàng, để à để làm TikTok rồi làm
YouTube ví dụ như vậy. Thì cái hướng đấy
là cái hướng mà học cách sử dụng công cụ
AI. Cái hướng này thì mình khẳng định
với các bạn luôn là nó sẽ là cái hướng
đi nó sẽ dễ hơn, tốn ít thời gian hơn và
các bạn cũng sẽ phải bỏ ra ít công sức
hơn. Cái hướng này thì thường nó sẽ phù
hợp với những người mà người ta đã có
công việc rồi và người ta muốn học cách
sử dụng AI hiệu quả hơn để có thể tăng
cái performance cho công việc của người
ta. Ví dụ các bạn là những người đã có
job ở một cái office nào đấy rồi. Các
bạn muốn ứng dụng AI đấy để ví dụ là tạo
video, tạo ảnh để chạy quảng cáo hoặc là
các bạn ví dụ các bạn là các cái kiến
trúc sư, các bạn muốn tạo ra những cái
bức ảnh về những căn nhà để cho khách
hàng xem trước, tức là bảo khách hàng
làm gì đây? Căn nhà của anh chị sau khi
xây xong trông lại như này. Thế kiểu
kiểu như vậy đúng không?
hoặc là có rất nhiều người ta sử dụng AI
để làm sao có thể ví dụ là để
không không chỉ là để tạo ra ảnh với
video mà nó còn các bạn có thể tạo ra
cái chiến lược kinh doanh rồi nhận xét ờ
đánh giá phân tích các thứ đúng không?
Tức là các bạn dùng các ngụ AI dưới góc
nhìn của end user là một người dùng
cuối. Các bạn học cách làm sao các bạn
có thể viết prom làm sao để viết prom
một cách nó tốt nhất, nó chuẩn chỉ nhất
để làm sao nó ra kết quả giống như các
bạn mong muốn. đấy là cái hướng đầu tiên
và cái hướng này là cái hướng mà đa số
mọi người
đa số mọi người người ta sẽ theo tại vì
là nó cần ít thời gian hơn nó thẳng ra
là nó cũng dễ hơn nữa và nó sẽ phục vụ
công việc của những người mà đã có chop
rồi. Vâng. Cái hướng thứ hai là cái
hướng mà chúng ta sẽ học AI truyền
thống. A truyền thống chính là cái mà
chúng ta sẽ học trong khóa học này. Khi
các học E truyền thống các bạn sẽ học
dưới góc nhìn của một người mà các bạn
muốn xây dựng sản phẩm. Các bạn sẽ học
từ đầu từ góc dễ. Tức là gì? Tức là
chúng ta không chỉ dùng những thứ có sẵn
mà chúng ta phải biết cách chúng ta tự
bự tự xây dựng sản phẩm từ gốc để làm
sao các bạn có thể hiểu cái cơ chế hoạt
động của nó. Vì sao các bạn cần phải
hiểu cơ chế hoạt động của AI? Tại vì các
bạn sẽ chỉ có thể tối ưu, các bạn chỉ có
thể điều chỉnh, các bạn sẽ chỉ có thể mở
rộng cái công cụ, các cái mô hình nếu
các bạn biết ở bản chất là nó hoạt động
như thế nào. Thế cái hướng này thì nó sẽ
khó hơn, nó sẽ tốn nhiều thời ăn hơn và
nó cũng sẽ dễ bỏ cuộc hơn.
Hướng này nó sẽ phù hợp thường nó sẽ phù
hợp với những bạn nào mà các bạn là sinh
viên các bạn có thời gian tại vì học
hướng này nó sẽ tốn rất nhiều thời gian
các bạn tưởng tượng nó giống như kiểu
các bạn học một cái chuyên ngành trên
trường đại học ấy đây cũng giống như vậy
tốn rất là nhiều thời gian và nó cũng sẽ
khó để các bạn đi đến cuối hơn ví dụ ví
dụ theo trải nghiệm của mình thì ờ thì
thường những cái lớp học của mình ấy số
lượng mà các bạn thực sự các bấy theo
được đến cuối có lẽ là nó cũng không quá
được 20% các bạn tin mình đi. Khi mà các
bạn bắt đầu học những cái buổi đầu của
học này, các bạn sẽ thấy là học AI để
xây dựng sản phẩm nó sẽ khác hoàn toàn
so với việc các bạn dùng cái AI dùng
Google AI các bạn chỉ gõ một vài dòng
prom là xong rất là dễ. Nhưng mà khi các
bạn học với ai dưới hướng truyền thống
này, các bạn sẽ phải học những cái thứ
nó nền tảng nó sẽ có ăn dân rất là
nhiều. Không chỉ là toán hay là lập
trình nó còn rất nhiều thứ khác nữa.
Ờ
mình thì mình hi vọng là trong quá trình
các bạn tham gia khoa học này, các bạn
coi như là các bạn đang học một cái
chương trình giống như chương trình
trường giống như là một cái chương trình
trên trường đại học vậy. Tức là gì? Tức
là các bạn không chỉ các bạn vào lớp,
các bạn một tuần các bạn cho vào hai
buổi, các bạn nghe mình mỗi buổi hai
tiếng tổng cầ 4 tiếng một tuần mà lúc ở
nhà các bạn cũng cố gắng làm sao các bạn
có thể sắp xếp một chút thời gian để các
bạn có thể xem lại bài giảng, các bạn
làm bài và có cái gì các bạn thấy các
bạn chưa hiểu các bạn có thể hỏi mình.
Cái điều này nó rất là quan trọng tại vì
mình biết là hầu hết các bạn học viên
của mình từ trước đến giờ ấy mọi người
đều học theo kiểu là đấy cứ đúng một
tuần là vào đúng 4 tiếng đồng hồ hai
buổi mỗi buổi hai tiếng. Thế thôi đến
tuần sau lại vác đúng cái xác vào. Không
ôn không không review, không không làm
cái gì cả. Cứ chỉ đúng một tuần cứ đủ
hai buổi như vậy. Thì nếu mà các bạn
không có quá trình các bạn ôn lại, các
bạn xem lại bài cũ cũng như là các bạn
có thể xem qua một chút về bài mới hay
là các bạn làm bài thì thì cái quá trình
học nó sẽ không có hiệu quả đúng. Các
bạn học trên trường cũng thế thôi, các
bạn bất kể các bạn học ngành gì cũng thế
thôi đúng không? Không chỉ lên giảng
đường là đủ mà về các bạn phải tự ôn lại
nữa. Thì tất nhiên cái khóa này nó không
phải là một cái khoa học chính thức ở
trên trường đại học. Mình cũng không có
một cái cơ chế nào để mình có thể bắt
mọi người là về bắt buộc phải làm bài
hay là phải xem lại bài. Thế nhưng mà
nói gì nói thì các bạn cũng các bạn cũng
phải tốn một khoản tiền để các bạn vào
đây học đúng không? Các bạn phải tốn một
khoản tiền thì mình rất là mong là làm
sao mà cái khoản tiền đấy các bạn đầu tư
một cách nó hiệu quả nhất đúng không?
Thì mình tin chắc chắn rằng nếu mà các
bạn học mà các bạn dành thời gian các
bạn có trách nhiệm với cái khoảng tiền
các bạn bỏ ra để các bạn học thì chắc
chắn là các bạn sẽ có một cái take away
gì đấy. Các bạn sẽ có những cái thu
hoạch nhất định dành cho mình. Đấy,
trong quá trình mình dạy thì mình không
sợ là dạy mà các bạn không hiểu, mình sợ
là các bạn không chịu học và các bạn
không hiểu, các bạn không hỏi thôi. Còn
các bạn hỏi thì mình rất là welcome nhá.
Mình rất là mong là rất là mong là sẽ
nhận được sự hợp tác đến từ các bạn để
làm sao cái quá trình học chúng ta nó
mang lại những cái trải nghiệm nó vui vẻ
nhất, nó vui vẻ nhất. Mình thì không bắt
buộc các bạn phải làm bài tập hay, không
bắt buộc các bạn phải làm cái gì cả
nhưng mà mình rất là mong là các bạn sẽ
sẽ
dành cái theo nhất định để các bạn có
thể ôn bài tập, bạn bài tập đúng không?
Đấy chương trình này mình đã thiết kế
chắc chắn là nó sẽ dễ hơn cái chương
trình các bạn học chương trình này học
cao đẳng thứ tại vì cái chương trình kia
là chương trình đoạn chính quy. Người ta
có nhiều thời gian hơn và người ta có
thể và cái chương trình này mình được
thiết kế để dành cho những bạn nào các
bạn muốn đi làm ở công ty chứ không phải
là các bạn đi theo hướng nghiên cứu Hàn
Lâm nên là những cái thứ gì mà chỉ phụ
kiểu đi những người nào đi sâu hướng
nghiên cứu hoặc là những người người ta
muốn ví dụ là ôn thi cuối kỳ chẳng hạn
thì người ta cần. Còn các bạn phụ cho
mục đích đi học thì tất nhiên nó vẫn có
những cái lý thuyết. Thế nhưng mà à phụ
cho cho đi làm thì sẽ có những cái thứ
mình sẽ giảm tải đi. Các bạn sẽ không
cần phải động vào những cái thứ quá là
cồng kềnh. Công thức toán quá là cồng
kềnh nhưng mà cũng sẽ phải có những một
vài công thức cơ bản chúng ta bắt buộc
chúng ta phải nắm được. Đấy thế đấy là
một vài cái lời mình muốn nói từ ban
đầu. Đấy các bạn tin mình đi. Các bạn
tin mình đi. Cứ 10 người học thì chắc là
chỉ có may mắn được hai người trụ đến
cuối thôi. Tại vì khi các bạn học các
bạn sẽ cần thấy là AI AI theo hướng
truyền thống học thuật ấy nó khó hơn rất
nhiều so với AI dùng công cụ nó khó hơn
rất rất nhiều. Và các bạn thấy là AI nó
không chỉ có những cái ngôi ngôn ngữ lớn
nó không chỉ có chat GBT mà nó còn có
rất nhiều cái thứ khác nữa và không phải
cái thứ nào trông nó cũng đẹp đẽ như
kiểu chat GBT
nhá. Đây là một vài lời đầu tiên mình
muốn nói với các bạn. Ok. Thế ờ trước
khi chúng ta bắt đầu vào những nội dung
đầu tiên, có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
không? Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào các bạn muốn hỏi cái gì
không?
Có bạn nào có bất kỳ cái thắc mắc gì
>> À vâng anh ơi cho em hỏi một chút của
đường ạ.
Em hỏi đi, em hỏi đi. Ờ
>> em kiểu em là em học toán các thứ em
cũng học toán không giỏi á thì không
biết là em
>> em có phù hợp với cả học chuyên sâu hay.
>> Ok. Ờ không sao không vấn đề các bạn ạ.
Trong quá trình học như mình nói rồi
những cái gì mà toán nó quá lằng nhằng
ma trận ma chủng thứ quá lằng nhằng mình
sẽ bỏ đi nhưng mà tất nhiên nó vẫn sẽ
những cái toán mình không thể bỏ được.
Thế nhưng mà đế cái phần nào cần kiến
thức gì thì mình sẽ bổ sung cho các bạn
nhá. Các bạn không phải lo nhá.
Ok.
>> Dạ vâng. M
>> ok cảm ơn em. Ok. Có b nào câu hỏi gì
nữa không?
Hỏi đi.
>> À dạ anh ơi em có à dạ thì như em đã
chia sẻ thì em thì em không có nền cẩn
quá vững về coding
về về em về về học kỹ thu học không thì
>> em không biết là khi mà học về khóa học
này
>> giống như là về học máy hay là data
sence thì em không biết là nó như thế
nào.
>> Ok. Ok rồi. Ok cảm ơn câu hỏi của em. Ok
thì câu hỏi em là em không có nên tảng
quá là mạnh về coding không có vấn đề gì
cả. Thì công ngữ chính chúng ta sẽ dùng
trong form này là Python. Python là một
ngữ nó cú pháp nó rất là đơn giản và
thật ra thì những cái thứ mà chúng ta
code trong khóa này nó team mình link nó
rất là basic thôi. Chúng ta sẽ có một
vài tức là trước khi chúng ta bắt đầu
chúng ta vào code những thứ liên quan
đến machining dat chúng ta sẽ có một vài
những cái bài tập làm quen trước là các
bạn sẽ không không có vấn đề gì đâu nhá.
Không phải lo cái đoạn đấy nhá.
Dạ cả ơn.
>> Ok em.
Ok. Có bạn nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Câu hỏi anh
là khi mà em học khóa học này xong thì
liệu em đã bắt đầu làm được những cái
project cá nhân mình chưa anh ấy?
>> Được chứ không cần phải học hết khóa
đâu. Trong quá trình học chúng ta cũng
đã làm rồi. Trong quá trình học chúng ta
đã sẽ nhìn nhau làm các cái project cá
nhân rồi nhá.
>> Em cảm ơn.
>> Ok.
Có b nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
À thế
em cho hỏi này khi công ty hiện lên à
thật ra này ờ mình thì không phải là đại
diện của công ty nên là rất là khó để
mình có thể thayệ công ty đấy nhưng mà
thông qua quá trình mình cũng xem xét
thị trường Việt Nam thì mình thấy là bây
giờ các cái job hiện nay các cái job
kiểu fresher nó đi nó yêu cầu rất là
cao. Đấy thật thật ra thì theo mình nhá,
theo mình ấy thì cái việc mà học thuần
AI ấy, cái việc học thuần AI nó sẽ
khá là cạnh tranh. Nó sẽ khá là cạnh
tranh. Do đó thì có một cái có một cái
hướng này mình thấy là nó sẽ nó sẽ mình
nghĩ là nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn cho các bạn
trong sự nghiệp. Đó là gì? Đó là các bạn
học một cái nếu các bạn đang học một cái
chuyên ngành nào đó và các bạn muốn học
AI để các bạn áp dụng vào chuyên ngành
đấy thì nó sẽ rất là tốt. Tức là gì? Các
bạn có một cái chuyên ngành chính và các
bạn muốn học AI để các bạn có thể
ứng dụng AI vào cái chuyên ngành đó của
bạn. Ví dụ là về cơ khí, về điện tử, về
tài chính, về ngân hàng gì đấy chẳng
hạn. Điều đấy nó rất là tốt. Nó rất là
tốt. Tại vì lúc đấy các bạn sẽ vừa có có
kiến thức của chuyên ngành đó, các bạn
lại vừa có kiến thức của AI. Còn nếu các
bạn chỉ học mỗi AI thôi ấ thì mình không
nói là không thể nhưng ý mình nói là cái
mức độ cạnh tranh nó sẽ nhiều hơn. Thế
học xong khóa này mình có thể phline
a được không anh? Ờ như thế này mà ờ ví
dụ như các bạn CV bình thường nhá các
bạn phải học những chương trình chuẩn 4
năm 5 năm ở trên trường đại học đúng
không? Học về AI học 4 5 năm đúng không?
Cái khóa này của mình có 2 tháng thôi.
Thế bây giờ những cái bạn 45 năm kia các
bạn appl trước còn được. Bây giờ khoa
học của mình học có 2 tháng thôi, học
xong và mình có thể apply an rồi thì có
khi là bây giờ sinh viên Bách Khoa, sinh
viên đối chứng biến thông chắc là bỏ hết
chắc là về học mình mất rồi đúng không?
Tất nhiên là ai học cũng muốn là xin
được việc. Thế nhưng mà ý mình là quá
trình việ nó sẽ không đơn giản như vậy
đúng không? Cái khoa học của mình mà
mình học có 2 tháng thôi mà đi xin được
appline được ti ngay ý thì vin viết các
thứ chắc là mời mình về dạy hết mất rồi
chứ mình không phải mời học lớp ngoài
này nữa nhá.
Và ngoài ra thì cái việc có appline được
không ấy nó còn phụ thuộc vào nhiều nó
còn phụ thuộc vào chính của các bạn nữa
đúng không? Nó phụ thuộc vào cái việc
mình dạy và nó phụ thuộc vào các bạn học
về cái khả năng của các bạn nữa. Nó còn
phụ vào nhiều yếu tố chứ không phải là
mình cứ dạy đúng không? Chứ bây giờ lớp
này mà ví dụ đây các bạn thấy có ba mươi
mấy bạn ba mấy bạn học xong đều appl
được AI hết thì thì
mình sẽ tự hào. Mình sẽ rất là tự hào.
Thế nhưng mà đ khó.
Ok. Có bạn nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Việt
>> cho mình hỏi cái chỗ apply job.
>> Dạ
>> là mình mình là có mình là engineer 10
khoảng 10 năm về Bend thì mình cũng
chuyển qua II á để mình mở rộng ra một
số cái tính năng của app app bên mình á.
Thì
khi mà mình muốn mình học xong những
khóa này á thì làm sao để mình apply vào
những cái job mà người ta yêu cầu 2 3
năm kinh nghiệm ờ về AI.
>> À ok. Thế
thế này mọi người ạ. Ờ thường ấy những
cái job mà người ta ghi là à NH5 kinh
nghiệm về AI ấy thường người ta đang nằm
thường người ta đang nói chung chung đến
tức là những cái bạn mà tức là kiểu mới
ra trường các bạn đấy bắt đầu tích lũy
kinh nghiệm thừ thế còn riêng ra riêng
với những người mà đã làm
N5 ở một cái mảng khác và chuyển sang ấy
thì thật ra ấy cái yêu cầu thực sự nó sẽ
nhỏ đi một chút. Còn nhất là với anh thì
anh làm engineering tức là nó là một cái
mảng nó khá tức là nó cũng là một cái
mảng kỹ thuật nó khá là gần gần gũi thì
cái yêu cầu nó sẽ nó sẽ nhỏ hơn. Tại vì
suy chùng ấy mọi người khi mà các bạn
thấy là những cái chop trong những cái
chop description người ta mô tả công
việc là 2 đến 3 năm hoặc là n ấy đúng
không? Tức là thật ra cái mà công ty cần
ấy không chỉ là cái kiến thức chuyên môn
về AI mà còn là kiến thức chuyên môn về
cái việc là ví dụ làm sao để có thể xây
dựng, có thể vận hành, có thể triển khai
sản phẩm. Đấy là cái thứ mà mình đã được
tích lũy trong quá trình làm engineer
rồi đấy. Thế còn thật ra gọi là làm a
engineer nhưng mà cái thời gian thực sự
khi chúng ta đi làm ấy mà thực sự những
cái công việc mà cần những cái thức về
AI ấy nó chiếm không quá 30%. Ví dụ như
mình mình làm AI nhưng mà cái thời gian
mà mình thực sự là mình huấn lệ mô hình
ấy nó không chiếm quá 30%. Còn thời gian
còn lại liên quan đến việc là chuẩn bị
dữ liệu này đúng không? Rồi có thể là
phân tích yêu cầu của khách hàng này
hoặc là triển khai mô hình. t những cái
thứ mà nó không
nó không thực sự liên quan đến AI nó là
những cái thứ mà nó kết hợp với AI đấy
nên là không phải là ờ nên là mọi người
đừng có lo cái việc là mình không đủ số
kinh nghiệm không không phải như vậy
mình sẽ có những cái thứ khác để mình có
thể mình có thể bù vào và nhất là việc
mình đã đi làm cái mảng engineer rồi thì
đấy là một cái lợi thế nghĩa là một cái
lợi thế rất là lớn
>> rồi cảm ơn vịạ anh chị em hỏi là sau khi
học phong
>> dạ
>> sau này chắc có gì phỏng vấn mình sẽ hỏi
>> nh nhất chí nhất chí
Anh ơi cho em hỏi là sau khi học khoa
học này mình có thể appl vào công ty yêu
cầu phỏng bọn em kinh nghiệm ờ về mặt
kiến thức thì anh thấy hoàn toàn ok nhá
về mặt kiến thức thì em hoàn toàn anh
khẳng định xong em học con qua này em
thể appl về công ty yêu cầu 1 2 năm kinh
nghiệm anh khẳng định là kiến thức thì
là đủ nhưng mà vấn đề là khi em ấy khi
em apply ấy đúng không thì liệu người ta
có mời mình vào phỏng vấn để em thể hiện
kiến thức đấy hay không nếu khi mà em
apply ấy em được mời em được người ta
mời đi phỏng vấn thì anh khẳng định luôn
nếu em học một cách gọi là chỉnh chu thì
những cái kiến thức form này nó thừa sức
cho em để em có thể apply em em để em có
thể trả lời câu hỏng vấn đấy. Thế nhưng
mà vấn đề là khi mà em nộp cái CV vào
liệu người ta nhìn vào CV người ta có
mời em đi phỏng vấn không đúng không? Ch
em không đấy em em sẽ khó để mình có thể
chưng ghi trong CV là tôi đã học một
khóa của anh Biề Nguyễn A trong vòng 2
tháng đúng không? Mời tôi đi phỏng vấn
đi đúng không? Rất là khó bây giờ quan
trọng làm sao để có thể được mời đi
phỏng vấn đã đúng không? Còn được mời
rồi thì anh khẳng định em là kiến thức
chắc nó là đủ.
>> Dạ em cảm ơn anh.
>> Ok. Ok. Ờ có b nào câu hỏi nữa không? Dạ
em muốn hỏi chút về cái cái lộ trình
đấyụ trong khóa này thì mình học cái gì
sau đấy tiếp sau thì mình học những cái
gì khác ấy những cái khóa [hắng giọng]
thường ý thì về lộ trình học người ta sẽ
bắt đầu là với dat và maching mình nó
nói trường hợp là các bạn ấy đã biết lập
trình python cơ bản hoặc là biết k thức
cơ bản phải về lập trình các bạn lập
trình ngôn ngữ khác cũng được tại vì p
nó rất cú pháp rất là dễ thôi đấy đầu
tiên là các bạn sẽ học về data và machin
thì khi mà học về data với machining ấy
thì cái mục tiêu là chúng ta sẽ sử dụng
cái mô hình để làm sao tôi có thể làm
việc với dữ liệu dạng bản thông thường
các cái mô hình trong machin truyền
thống người ta sẽ dữ liệu tập bà là
những cái file Excel là file CSV. Thế
thì sau khi mọi người học xong
machining, học xong data rồi thì chúng
ta sẽ học tiếp đến deep learning. Khi mà
học về deep link nó sẽ có hai cái mảng
hai hướng tùy xem là các bạn thích làm
việc với kiểu gì bạn nào các bạn thích
làm việc ví dụ dạng văn bản tài liệu thì
các bạn sẽ theo cái hướng là deep
learning for Nature Language processing.
Tức là mảng sử ngữ tự nhiên đó. Đấy. Thế
còn cái mảng thứ hai là cái mảng của
mình, cái mảng chuyên môn của mình. Cái
mảng của mình theo sung suốt ngày hôm
nay đó là mảng diing for computer vision
các bạn sẽ làm việc với ảnh hoặc là làm
với video. Thế hai cái mảng này từ ngày
xưa là một ngày thường chỉ chọn 1.2
thôi. Còn bây giờ sẽ có nhiều người ta
chơi cả hai luôn. Chơi cả hai mảng luôn.
Với cái mảng NLP thì mấy năm gần đây nó
rất là hot. Tại vì là chúng ta có cái
mảng là các cái mùi ngôn ngữ lớn là một
cái mảng con của NLP. Và những mạng các
bạn muốn xây dựng chatbot, xây dựng
Asient các thứ thì nó là cái mảng con
của NP. Đấy đấy thì cái lộ trình tùy
theo các bạn thích đeo cái hướng nào có
người ta chỉ ra một hướng thôi, có người
người ta chơi cả hai.
Ờ kế luận chia sẻ về cái cái lúc làm
project nào thì trong quá trình học đến
lúc nào liên quan mình sẽ mình sẽ cài
vào nhá.
>> Anh ơi bài tập của anh giao ở bên mình
thì là mình chủ yếu làm code hay là mình
sẽ làm bài như thế nào anh nhỉ? Chủ yếu
là đúng rồi chủ yếu là code ngay tuần
đầu tiên mình sẽ những cái bài code cơ
bản mình làm quen với cái thư viện ví dụ
n hoặc là panas chẳng hạn những cái bài
sau khi mà chúng ta bắt đầu chúng ta vào
cái buổi thực hành về rồi chúng ta sẽ
bắt đầu chúng ta học cách chúng ta huấn
luyện cho đánh giá cái mô hình nhá.
>> Vâng. Thế cái về cái phần làm bài này
thì mình có phải cài đặt hay là xây dựng
môi trường trước không?
>> À không cần đâu. Mình dùng các cái thư
viện đơn giản thôi. Đến lúc nào mà chúng
ta phần thực hành đấy mình sẽ chỉ mọi
người xem cần phải dùng thư viện gì.
Thật ra ấy mình không chỉ thì khi mà các
bạn code ấy nó có lỗi là các bạn nhìn ra
ngay thiếu cái gì các bạn biết ngay mà.
Thế nhưng mà thế hôm trước không thực
hành mình sẽ chỉ các bạn nhá. Trước hôm
chúng ta bắt đầu thực hành về ming chỉ
các bạn phải cài thờ viện gì nhá.
>> Vâng vâng em cảm ơn anh.
>> Ok
có nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Có smart gì nữa không?
Ờ có một cái điểm như này nữa không?
Khóa này không phải khóa chuyên về. Cái
khóa chuyên về là cái khóa mà sáng mai
10 giờ khai giảng cơ. không phải khóa
này.
Ờ
có một cái điểm này các bạn nhá. Ờ nói
về nói về code đi. Nói về code thì chúng
ta thường chúng ta sẽ dùng ví dụ ví dụ
nhá thông thường thông thường nhá các
cái khóa học về AI, về data science, về
machining ấy hoặc là về thậm chí là về
Python người ta rất hay người ta
cho học viên tức là các bạn ấy lập trình
trên những cái thứ như kiểu là ờ Jupiter
Notebook hoặc là Google Collab nhá.
Jupiter Notebook là Google Collab. Thông
thường ví dụ ngày xưa hồi mình học ở
tuonic nó cũng thế. Các cái hòa về
machining người ta hay dùng Google à
dùng Jupiter Notebook. Cái ưu điểm của
Jupiter Notebook là gì? Là dùng rất là
đơn giản, rất là trực quan đúng không?
Các bạn code ở từng ô một, mỗi một ô các
bạn code vài dòng code các bạn chạy xem
nó ra kết quả gì các bạn code tiếp đúng
không? Kiểu code tuyến tính như vậy đúng
không? Ngày xưa nó chính là cái kiểu lập
trình mà hồi cấp ba chúng ta học đấy
đúng không? Người ta gọi là lập trình
hướng. Hướng gì? Hướng cấu trúc. Lập
trình hướng cấu trúc đúng không? Cứ dòng
nào code trước chạy trước, dòng nào code
sau chạy sau. Đó, viết tuyến tính từ
trên xuống dưới. Thế nhưng mà trong form
này mình sẽ không dạy các bạn với vi
notebook, mình sẽ dùng thẳng id luôn. ID
là cái gì? ID bạn các bạn chưa biết ID
bạn hiểu nó là một cái môi trường, nó là
một cái nó gọi là một cái công cụ để cho
các bạn code rồi các bạn có thể fixedb
các thứ trên đấy. Ờ mình thì mình không
mình thì mình không muốn là dạy các bạn
theo dướu là dùng notebook. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì notebook nó chỉ phù hợp cho người
mới học thôi. Tất nhiên các bạn ấy cũng
là người mới học cả th nhưng mà mình
thấy một cái đặc điểm là gì là ai mà đã
quen dùng notebook rồi rất là dễ bị
nghiện không thoát ra được tại vì dùng
nó rất là nó nó rất là tiện code từng
ngô từng ngô chạy là xong. Thế nhưng mà
vi notebook hoặc là Google Colab ấ nó có
những cái hợp điểm là gì? Là khi các bạn
chỉ code những chương trình bé bé thì
không sao. Chương trình nhỏ nhỏ xinh
xinh thì không sao. Nhưng mà khi các bạn
code những chương trình to, chương trình
thực tế thì các bạn sẽ gặp rất nhiều khó
khăn. Và thứ hai nữa là gì? Là sau này
khi mà các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ làm
việc ở những cái project rất là lớn, rất
là khổng lồ. có thể có hàng triệu dòng
code nó có rất nhiều những cái file code
đặt ở những chỗ khác nhau. Các bạn mà
dùng Zoom notebook các bạn không quen
với việc là tổ chức cấu trúc thư mục các
thứ ấy và các bạn không quen việc là các
bạn đặt break point, các bạn deb các thứ
ấy thì sau này khi các bạn làm những
project thực tế các bạn đi hỏng công ty
rất là khó khăn. Đấ
thế nên là ngay từ đầu mình sẽ cho các
bạn làm quen luôn với việc sử dụng các
cái ID. Tất nhiên nếu mà các bạn làm bài
hoặc trong quá trình học các bạn vẫn
thích dùng ZU thì cũng ok thôi. Thế
nhưng mà theo mình các bạn nên làm quen
với việc sử dụng ID vì ID nó sẽ là cái
thứ sau các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ dùng.
Chả ai đi code trong môi trường thực tế
lại đi dùng. Tức là những cái thứ đơn
giản thì không sao. Thế nhưng mà dùng
thì nó vẫn sẽ tốt hơn. Có cuối khóa này
có thời gian mình sẽ dạy về doer nhá.
Cuối khóa có thể mình sẽ dạy về docker
nhá. Dùng ID. Thế thì các cái ID dành
cho Python ấy thì các bạn có rất nhiều
sự lựa chọn nhưng mà trong đó thì có hai
sự lựa chọn phổ biến nhất. Một là PAM và
hai là VS Code. Các bạn dùng cái nào
cũng được. Mỗi cái nó có một cái ưu
điểm. VS Code thì nó có ưu điểm nó rất
là đa di đăng. Các bạn có thể vừa code
Python các bạn vừa code nhiều ngôn ngữ
khác. Các bạn code JavaScript, các bạn
code
code C C+ng các bạn code Java Code nhiều
ngữ cùng lúc rất là ok. Và nó cũng rất
có rất nhiều packit rất là hữu ích. Ờ
với mình thì mình dùng Phan mình dùng
Phan. Pam này nó chỉ hỗ trợ Python thôi.
Thế nhưng mà Phan là một cái ID rất là
nổi tiếng dành cho Python. Và nếu mà các
bạn nếu mà các bạn các bạn code cái nào
cũng được. Các bạn đang dùng VS Code các
bạn code tiếp vay VS Code cũng được. Thế
nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn dùng PAM giống
như mình ấy thì có cái vấn đề gì các bạn
dùng trục chặc ấy thì trong quá trình
các bạn sử dụng thì có gì thì mình sẽ hỗ
trợ nó dễ hơn. Còn VS Code thì mình
không có thạo lắm. V code mình không có
thạo lắm nên các bạn dùng khác mình nó
sẽ hơi khó để mình hỗ trợ. Đấy đấy là
cái đây là cái thứ nhất đấy. Tức là
chúng ta sẽ làm quen với việc ID ngay từ
đầu là ngay từ đầu để cho các bạn luyện
cái thói quen một cái thói quen. Đ cái
thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai là liên quan đến
vi coding. Ờ sau này các bạn khi mà các
bạn đi làm công ty các bạn dùng vi
coding thoải mái. Thế nhưng mà trong quá
trình học thì mình vẫn muốn là
mình vẫn là muốn tại vì cái khoa này
chúng ta hướng đến việc là chúng ta hiểu
bản chất nên mình muốn là các bạn làm
sao trong quá trình học này các bạn cố
gắng các bạn hạn chế. Trừ khi các bạn
dùng các bạn dùng AI thì các bạn đi tìm
thông tin đã đành. Nhưng mà mình mong
các bạn là các bạn đừng dùng AI để code
mình cần các bạn phải tự code được. Còn
một khi các bạn sau này các bạn đã tự
code được rồi các bạn dùng AI thoải mái
không có vấn đề gì đúng không? Sau này
các bạn đi làm, các bạn dùng e thoải
mái, các bạn đi làm bài kiểm tra lớp,
các bạn dùng e thoải mái. Thế nhưng mà
trong quá trình học thì mình mong là các
bạn cố các bạn tự code, các bạn tự code
nhá. Chỉ khi nào chúng ta tự làm chúng
ta mới có thể chúng ta nắm được, hiểu
được bản chất. Được chưa? Chúng ta hãy
học như thể rằng không có các cái AI
coding agent nhá. Đây là cái thứ hai.
Ờ có một cái nữa, có một cái nữa thì ờ
mình cũng thuộc dạng là làm mở và bán
khóa học đúng không? Ờ trong quá trình
mà mình tuyển sinh ấy có rất nhiều bạn
có thể hỏi mình những cái thứ như là ừ
thứ nhất là cam kết đầu ra. Thứ nhất là
cái cam kết đồ ra. Có rất nhiều bạn hỏi
mình là anh có cam kết đầu ra hay không?
Thì ờ từ trước đến giờ tất cả những cái
lớp mình học mình biết là có rất nhiều
cái nơi khác họ cam kết là
support các bạn cho đến khi các bạn xin
việc rồi cam kết này kia. Thế nhưng mà
với mình không có cam kết. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì ờ cái việc học như mình nói rồi
nó đến từ hai phía. Nó đến từ phía cả
phía mình và cả phía người học nữa. Thế
ờ nếu mình c biết kết đầu ra nó sẽ có
những trường hợp là có những bạn vào các
bạn ấy chả học gì. Nhưng mà vì các bạn
có cam kết rồi, các bạn cứ cứ ngựa xem
hoa rồi đến cuối các bạn ấy cứ anh ơi em
nhất định là anh cam kết rồi anh phải
cho em tìm cách giúp em vào công ty thì
nó sẽ rất là khó cho mình đúng không? Nó
rất là khó cho mình. Cái việc cam kết
đầu ra thực sự là nó sẽ rất là khó cho
mình. Nó rất là khó cho mình tại vì là
mình cũng không mình cũng mình cũng
không phải là một ông sếp có hàng nghìn
slot để có thể giới thiệu các bạn vào
đúng không? Ờ cái việc học này thì cái
khóa này của mình mình mở ra với mục
đích chính là để cung cấp cho bạn những
cái kiến thức và cả những cái kinh
nghiệm trong quá trình mình làm nữa chứ
đây không phải là một khóa kiểu gọi là
đào tạo ngắn hạn để tạo ra công nhân đi
làm. Không phải như vậy. Đây là cái thứ
nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là có rất nhiều
bạn hỏi mình về cái kiểu là certificate.
Certificate là chứng chỉ thì thật ra
mình cũng biết là có rất nhiều bên họ
làm tạo ra cái chứng chỉ tức là kiểu
chứng chỉ là các bạn đã học làm gì nào
đấy. Nhưng mà thật ra theo mình thì
những cái chứng chỉ đấy mình có thể làm
rất là dễ thôi. Bây giờ hỏi ch chat
chatt mình có thể tạo ra 10 chứng chỉ
khác nhau. Các bạn thích cái nào mình
lấy cho các bạn cái đấy. Thế nhưng mà
theo mình cái việc cứu chứng chỉ này thì
nó cũng chả có ý nghĩa mấy. Tại vì các
bạn cho vào trong CV các bạn đã học cái
khóa học của ông Việt AI thì
nó cũng có để làm gì đâu. với mình thì
có chứng chỉ mà không có thực chất thì
cũng chả để làm gì cả. Thế nên là nếu mà
các bạn nào thực sự có nhu cầu có chứng
chỉ thì mình có thể làm được thôi. Mình
đã làm mình làm một cái template rồi thế
nhưng mà mình mới thắng được vào nhau là
mình cũng không muốn làm chứng chỉ tại
không phải là vì keyboard gì với các bạn
đâu. Nhưng mà vấn đề là chứng chỉ rồi
làm cái gì đúng không? Khi các bạn đi
phỏng vấn người ta cần các bạn có kiến
thức chứ còn chìa cái chứng chỉ có làm
gì đâu đúng không? Cái chứng là nó sẽ
không có ý nghĩa giống như kiểu bằng đại
học. Bằng đại học là cái thứ người ta có
thể chứng minh được. Tại vì các bạn đã
học phải qua mấy năm trời đúng chứ còn
cái khóa học 2 tháng chứng chỉ có để làm
cái gì đâu đúng không? kể những cái khóa
như kiểu cosera các thứ mình thấy chứng
chỉ không đánh giá cao lắm tại vì là nhá
doesn't matter đúng không
không nhờ gì ý nghĩa thế và mình cũng có
nhiều bạn hỏi là em có thể xem các
feedback của các bạn học à học phên cũ
được không thì thật ra ấy ngày hồi hồi
mình mới dạy học ngày xưa ấy mình cũng
trên cái fanpage của mình mình cũng tạo
ra cái chỗ để feedback mà các bạn này
nhớ thật các bạn nhá cái feedback ấy nó
thật là fake dễ lắm fake nó rất là dễ
mình thể tạo ra một trong cái tài khoản
fake rồi mình ghi cái nội dung là anh
Việt dạy hay lắm các thứ thì nó cũng chả
điểm gì và các bạn hiểu không những cái
những Cái nơi người ta dạy giống như
mình ấy đúng không? Nếu có feedback giờ
thì cũng chả qua người ta dạy mà người
ta lại show ra đúng không? Ví dụ bây giờ
có một bạn học viên cũ ph là ông Việt
dạy dạy dở hơi lắm chẳng hạn đúng không?
Đời nào mình lại show lên đúng không?
Còn bây giờ muốn feedback đúng không?
Mình sẽ mình mỗi khóa mình mình dạy xong
mình hoàn toàn thể nhờ các bạn học viên
là viết feedback mà mình chỉ có thể mình
chỉ giữ lại cái nào tốt thôi đúng không?
Và các bạn học viên viết cho mình thì
cũng ch viết tốt thôi chứ làm gì có ai
viết kiểu dở đâu. Nên là cái việc mà các
bạn thích feedback thì mình có thể làm
được thôi rất là dễ đế nhưng mà mình
cũng thấy là nó cũng chả có ý nghĩa mấy
thế. Thế nên là khóa của mình thực sự
cái mà quan trọng nhất mình muốn trao
cho các bạn đó là kiến thức và những cái
trải nghiệm cũng như là kinh nghiệm của
cá nhân mình. Đấy, còn những cái thứ mà
liên quan đến hình thức ví dụ như là
bằng hoặc là đấy certificate hoặc là
feedback thực sự là mình không có làm
hoặc là cam kết đầu ra mình cũng không
có làm tại vì là có cái thì mình không
đủ khả năng để mình làm, có cái là mình
thấy là làm nó cũng chả điểm gì cả nhá.
Đấy thì ờ để tránh là tại vì mình biết
là thường kho bên ngoài nó sẽ có một cái
cam kết có một cái commitment gì đấy
nhưng mà mình mình chả có cam kết gì cả.
Đấy nhưng mà mình nói vậy để cho các bạn
cảm thấy là đó nó tự tin hơn khi các bạn
tham gia cái kho này. Mình không mình
không cam kết mình không hứa cái gì
không phải là không phải là không phải
là mình dạy dở hơi dở hồn gì đâu mà mà
là mình thấy là nó không phải là cái thứ
mà nó quan trọng nhất với các bạn khi mà
các bạn đến với mình nhá.
Ok. Thế ok thôi giới thiệu qua một chút
về bạn về các thứ đấy là ok rồi đúng
không? Thì chúng ta sẽ vào nội dung
chính các bạn nhá.
>> Bây giờ đây cho mình hỏi một câu nhỏ nó
nó liên quan cũng liên quan một chút đến
cái lộ trình với cả một cái cả Việt vừa
nói sáng nay anh em có khai giảng cái
lớp và cái gì đúng không?
>> Sáng mai. Sáng mai chứ không phải sáng
nay ạ. Sáng mai.
>> Sáng mai. Sáng mai sáng nay. Nhưng mà ờ
mình chỉ hỏi để hiểu ví dụ như mình ờ
biết bên cạnh cái khái niệm LLM ấy nó có
thêm một cái khái niệm làm
laer multimodel. À ok. À thế này ạ.
Trong cái khóa đấy là việc cũng có đề
cập đến những cái đấy cho các bạn đúng
không? Cũng truyền tải kiến thức về
những cái đấy quá đúng. Dạ. Multimodel ở
đây là gì? Tức là bình thường ấy khi mà
nói về các ngôn ngữ lớn là người ta
thường hay nói về input là dạng dạng
text, dạng văn bản. Đúng rồi.
>> Thế thế còn m tức là cái input nó bao
gồm có thể là cả ảnh và cả thậm chí là
cả audio nữa. Đấy thì nó nó khác biệt nó
là như vậy thôi. Có trong đấy em em có
nói
>> tại vì trong trong cái tờ lộ trình Việt
anh có mình có xem thì
nóiên về lm không [hắng giọng] không có
nhắt gì đế em em đi hỏi để tại vì là hầu
hết hầu hết các cái dữ liệu mọi người
hay làm việc làm dữ liệu là văn bản là
cái dữ liệu phổ biến nhất. Thế còn với
các ng lớn ảnh các thứ nó cũng có nhưng
mà nó không có phổ biến bằng. phổi mạc
tại vì là nên là em dạy em chỉ lôi cái
thứ t khi mà ghi qua học thì em chỉ ghi
những cái gì mà nó comment nhất thôi con
cũng không
>> nó nó là cái cơ bản nhất nhưng mà trong
quá trình học việc cũng truyền đạt lại
những cái kiến thức đấy đúng chính chắc
chắn chắc chắn chắc chắn
>> đúng đúng ok cảm ơn được
>> của em là khóa nếu mình nhớ nh ừ mình
thứ tự mình không nhớ là khóa số 5 ừ dạ
đúng rồi khóa số 5 khóa học này đơn
thuần khóa học này không chỉ khóa này
đâu mà tất cả các khóa đều là về python
cả tất cả các khóa đều là đều là sử dụng
python cả python ngữ số 1 dành cho AI
dành cho data dành cho machining. Rồi
tất cả các khóa của mình đều là về
Python cả.
Ok có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Ok chúng ta vào nội dung chính các bạn
nhá. Vào nội dung chính các bạn nhá. Đấy
thì mình muốn nói các bạn là ờ
cái mà mình thực sự mình kỳ vọng là mình
mang lại cho các bạn đó là kiến thức. Có
thể là những kể cả những cái kinh nghiệm
trong quá trình mình đi làm. Những cái
thứ mà mình thấy nó hay thứ mình thấy nó
thú vị. và thấy một thứ mình thấy là nó
sẽ giúp cho các bạn trong quá trình các
bạn xây dựng CV, xây dựng profile. Thì
bản thân mình ngày xưa cái hồi ngày xưa
mình lúc mình bắt đầu mình đi làm mình
cũng làm gì có kinh nghiệm đâu. Mình
cũng là từng người đang là một người
từng phải xây dựng CV từ con số 0. Thì
mình chia bạn cái cách mình ngày xưa
mình xây dựng CV profile nào để mình xin
việc ở bên kia. Có thể là giữa Đức Việt
Nam có thể nó sẽ không match trong với
100% nhưng mà mình tin là nó cũng sẽ
không ít thì nhiều. Nó không bổ chỗ này
nó cũng bổ chỗ kia. Đấy và có nhắc là
những cái kiến thức thì mình cũng rất là
mình biết là AI nó một lý vực rất là
khó. Đó mình biết là có những bạn bạn
các bạn đến mình xong sau khi các bạn đã
học chữ độ chỗ khác rồi các bạn nó không
có hiệu quả thì mình khá là tự tin việc
là mình có thể sao mình có thể giải
thích cho các bạn những thứ phức tạp
theo một cách mà đơn giản dễ hiểu. Đấy
thì kiến thức với mình kiến thức và kinh
nghiệm là những cái thứ mà mình sẽ hy
vọng là mình có thể chuyển lại mình có
thể chia sẻ lại cho các bạn. Đấy là cái
quan trọng nhất.
Ok thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói qua một
chút về cái nội dung chính của khóa này
các bạn nhá. Thì như các bạn nhìn trên a
từ mình quên từ mình quên quên mất cái
khóa mình sẽ là khóa đầu tiên mà mình sẽ
dùng với slide mới mình quên mất mình
quên mất nhầm các bạn đang mải nói ờ cái
slide cũ này là cái slide mà đ mình đã
dùng trong vòng hơn 3 năm nay rồi từ
cuối 2022 quên mất khóa mình là sẽ dùng
slide mới. Các bạn chờ một tí mình cứ
hay quen tay chờ một tí chúng ta sẽ dùng
slide mới. Chờ một tí nhá. Mình là khóa
đầu tiên slide mới. Có một vài cái
update mình sẽ cho vào đây.
Wait a second.
Chờ mình một tí nhá. Mình xem nó nằm ở
đâu đã. Quên mất cứ mải nói.
Các bạn chờ một xíu nha.
À đây rồi đây rồi đây rồi. Slide cũ này
cắt đi thôi. Slide này slide cũ. Chư giờ
mình đều dạy theo slide này. Nhưng mà
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ có slide mới.
Các bạn chờ mình một tí nhá. Chơi mình
một tí mình mình mình mở ra.
Có có có sau buổi này sau buổi này tầm
tối nay hoặc là m nhất là sáng mai mình
sẽ tạo ra một cái một cái folder trên
Google Drive rồi mình sẽ tất cả các thứ
slide rồi bài tập rồi code rồi record
các thứ mình cho vào đấy hết nhá.
Các bạn chờ mình một xíu
cho ch cho mình một xíu nhá.
Rồi
đây
nhá. À chúng ta sẽ bn nội chúng ta sẽ bn
nội dung chính của khóa này. Được chưa?
Thế đây là một vài những cái mục tiêu mà
chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau cùng nhau cố gắng
đặt ở trong khóa học này. Đầu tiên là về
mặt kiến thức. Mà kiến thức thì mình sẽ
trang bị cho các bạn những cái kiến thức
nền tảng quan trọng
từ cơ bản đến nâng cao về AI, về dat và
về machining. Đấy cả về lý thuyết cũng
như là thực hành và làm sao để các bạn
có thể ứng dụng để có thể giải quyết các
cái bài toán khác nhau. Thế [khịt mũi]
ngoài ra thì mình cũng sẽ làm sao mình
sẽ cố gắng làm sao mình có thể truyền
tải các bạn cách để các bạn có thể tư
duy đứ làm sao mà khi các bạn nhìn vào
một cái bài toán, các bạn nhìn vào một
cái bộ dữ liệu, các bạn biết là mình sẽ
phải sử dụng mô hình gì, các bạn phải đi
hướng tiếp cận nào, vì sao các bạn lại
dùng mô hình này mà không phải mô hình
kia. Nếu mà các bạn muốn cải thiện mô
hình, các bạn phải tập trung vào đâu?
Nếu mà quá trình huấn luyện, quá trình
đánh giá mà kết quả nó không bị như mong
muốn thì lỗi là từ dữ liệu hay là lỗi là
từ mô hình hay là lỗi từ cả hai. Làm sao
để tìm ra? Tìm ra xong rồi thì khắc phục
như thế nào đúng không? Thế tất cả những
thứ liên quan đến tư duy, liên quan đến
mindset, liên quan đến analytic thì mình
cũng sẽ chia sẻ với các bạn nhá. Và tất
nhiên là chúng ta không thể thiếu thực
hành. Ờ cái khóa này của chúng ta khoảng
sáu buổi đầu tiên là thuần chỉ có lý
thuyết thôi. Sáu buổi đầu tiên thuần chỉ
có lý thuyết. Sau đó là sẽ có ba buổi
thực hành liên tiếp. Sau đó là từ đấy
đến cuối khóa là cứ so le là một lý
thuyết một thực hành. Ờ tất nhiên đến
với mình mình biết là có rất nhiều bạn
các bạn mong muốn là sẽ được thực hành
thật là nhiều. Các bạn muốn code rất là
nhiều. Thế nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ chỉ cái
việc code ấy, cái việc thực hành ấy nó
việc nó không khó và nó sẽ chỉ có hiệu
quả khi mà chúng ta nắm rõ, chúng ta
hiểu rõ được bản chất thôi. Đấy cái việc
code, cái việc ngồi gõ code nó không có
khó một chút nào. Nó chỉ hiệu quả khi mà
các bạn hiểu rõ bản chất thôi. Thế mình
không muốn biến các bạn thành những
người thợ code là cứ ngồi gọi thư viện
rồi chạy rồi ra kết quả mà các bạn không
biết là ở phía sau nó cái gì. Mình muốn
là gì? Thì là khi mà các bạn code thậm
chí là sau này các bạn có thể dùng vi
coding nhưng mà nó tự sinh ra code các
bạn nhưng mà các bạn hiểu là à cái dòng
này nó làm cái gì, ở phía sau nó có cái
gì, mô hình nó được thiết kế như thế
nào, nó hoạt động ra làm sao hay là vì
sao nó lại đưa ra kết quả như vậy. Thì
đấy là cái mà mình nhắm đến nhá. Chúng
ta cũng sẽ sử dụng các cái framework,
các cái thư viện quan trọng và phổ biến
trong AI, trong data sence, trong
machining thì chúng ta sẽ là lượt chúng
ta làm quen trong quá trình chúng ta làm
bài tập cũng như là học nhá. Đây là một
vài những cái mục tiêu của khóa học này.
Được chưa?
Hóa nay thực hoạch nó sẽ rơi vào khoảng
45%. Lý thuyết khoảng 55%. Ờ lý thuyết
tất nhiên là không ai thích lý không ai
thích lý thuyết quả nhưng mà mình sẽ cố
gắng dạy theo cách nào để các bạn thấy
nó bớt nhàm chán nhất có thể nhá. Các
bạn tin mình đi khi mà các bạn đi phỏng
vấn ấy, trước khi các bạn đự động vào
code là người ta phải phỏng vấn các bạn
lý thuyết trước đúng không? Lý thuyết mà
các bạn không trả lời được thì chẳng ai
người ta cho các bạn vào coding
challenge hay là practical hoặc là hoặc
là kiểu gọi là technical interview đâu
nhá. Được chưa? Tiếp theo nhá. Tiếp theo
thì đây là ờ đây là đây là đây là những
cái nội dung chính mà chúng ta sẽ cùng
nhau trải qua trong khóa học này. Chúng
ta sẽ tìm hiểu về bốn thứ. Thứ nhất là
về dữ liệu. Với tất cả những ai làm về
AI ấy thì bình thường khi mà các bạn học
ở trên các cái chương trình đại học đào
tạo chính quy trên các trường cao đẳng
như đại học mà về AI, về datacent, về
machining ấy thì thường phần lớn thời
gian người ta sẽ dùng để người ta nói về
các cái mô hình, các cái thuật toán. Thế
nhưng mà thật ra ấy trong AI data
machining ấy cái thứ quan trọng mình
không nói là mô hình nó không quan trọng
nhưng mà cái thứ quan trọng nó không chỉ
có mô hình không chỉ có thuật toán mà nó
có cả dữ liệu nữa. Dữ liệu chính là cái
tài nguyên đầu vào chúng ta đưa vào
trong mô hình. Mô hình của các bạn bất
kể nó có cao siêu, nó có phức tạp đến
mấy đi nữa mà dữ liệu đầu vào nó không
tốt, nó không đủ thì mô hình chúng ta
cũng không thể nào chúng ta dự án tốt
được. Kể cả những cái công cụ như là
trangt đúng không? để những công cụ này
nó có thể làm đối với tốt như vậy thì ở
phía sau người ta cũng đã phải huấn
luyện chúng với rất rất nhiều dữ liệu
thì nó mới có khả năng nó làm việc tốt
như vậy đúng không? Thì chúng ta sẽ tìm
hiểu về dữ liệu.
Thế và sau này khi các bạn đi làm các
bạn sẽ thấy là gì? Cái thời gian các bạn
khi mà các bạn làm AI engineer, các bạn
làm data scientist ấy cái thời gian các
bạn làm việc về cung dưới rượu ấy nó còn
nhiều hơn thời gian các bạn làm việc về
mô hình. Tại vì mô hình hay là tội toán
sau này người ta đã open short người ta
đưa vào các cái thư viện hết rồi gọi rất
là dễ thôi. Đấy nhưng mà cái là các bạn
làm việc về dữ liệu làm sao để tôi có dữ
liệu. Có dữ liệu xong tôi xử lý nó thế
nào tốn rất nhiều thời gian. Thì đây cái
thứ nhất là cái dữ liệu. Cái thứ hai
chúng ta sẽ nói về chúng ta sẽ nói về
các cái thuật toán machining. Cái thuậ
toán machining này nó chính là nó chính
là cái chìa khóa để chúng ta có thể
chúng ta biến cái rượu chúng ta thành
những cái thông tin có có ý nghĩa. Khi
chúng ta học về các tổ toán trong
machining, chúng ta sẽ học cách làm sao
để tôi có thể xây dựng tôi huấn luyện
một cái mô hình để nó có thể đưa ra
những cái dự đoán. đưa ra cái dự đoán
thì trong machining nó có rất nhiều thán
khác nhau. Chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau tìm
hiểu các cái thuật toán mà ờ phổ biến
nhất, quan trọng nhất và có nhiều ứng
dụng nhất.
Tiếp theo sau trước khi mà chúng ta học
về machining, chúng ta sẽ đồng thời
chúng ta học về data. Machining và data
là hai cái mảng mà có rất nhiều những
cái sự trùng lặp, có rất nhiều những cái
sự tương hỗ với nhau. Những ai mà muốn
trở thành một data scientist thì không
thể nào thiếu các cái kiến thức về
machining. Và những ai muốn trở thành
một machining engineer thì cũng chẳng
thể nào thiếu các kiến thức về data
sence. Tí nữa chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau nói
về cái mối quan hệ giữa dat và
machining. Nhưng mà các bạn hiểu cách
đơn giản là gì? Là chúng là hai cái mảng
đúng đó rất là gần gũi với nhau. Rất là
gần gũi với nhau trong ông này và có cả
ông kia.
Ờ và tất nhiên là trong chương trình học
chúng ta cũng sẽ cùng nhau nói về các
cái bài toán, các cái ứng dụng làm sao
để chúng ta có thể áp dụng các cái kiến
thức của chúng ta. Chúng ta áp dụng kiến
thức về dữ liệu, về machining, về dat để
chúng ta có thể giải quyết các cái bài
toán thực tế thông qua quá trình chúng
ta thực hành, chúng ta xây dựng nh những
cái project để chúng ta có thể đưa ra
những cái dự đoán hoặc là đưa ra những
cái gợi ý cho người dùng chẳng hạn. Ví
dụ như vậy thì đấy là bốn cái nội dung
chính mà chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau đi qua
trong cái khóa học này.
Ok.
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không? Có nào có câu
hỏi gì không? Tí nữa mình sẽ gửi cho bạn
cái slide này nhá. Tí mình gửi cho bạn
[hắng giọng] cái slide tức là sau buổi
hôm nay mình sẽ up tất cả từ tài điện
tho lên trên Google Drive cho các bạn
nhá.
Tiếp này. Tiếp này.
À đầu tiên này các bạn này. Mình muốn
hỏi các bạn một câu này. Ờ vì sao bây
giờ các cái công cụ AI nó đã rất là phát
triển rồi đúng không? Rất nhiều các cụ
AI nó rất là tốt rồi đúng không? Chúng
ta mà có học AI, chúng ta có học
machining, chúng ta có học ấy khả năng
cao chúng ta cũng không thể nào chúng ta
tạo ra đện trệ mô hình nó tốt hơn chat
GBT đúng không? chúng ta có ngồi học 2
tháng hay là hai 2 năm hay là 20 năm nữa
thì rất là khó để chúng ta có thể tạo ra
mô hình nó tốt hơn ch chat chatbt. Thế
vì sao chúng ta có những công cụ AI rất
là thông minh, rất là toàn năng rồi mà
chúng ta vẫn phải
vẫn phải tự mình xây dựng rồi tự mình
huấn luyện các cái mùi AI. Lý do là vì
sao?
Lý do là vì sao?
Private data là một ví dụ nhưng nó cũng
không phải là không phải là tất cả. Tại
vì private data người ta hoàn toàn người
ta có thể tự host các cái mô hình LM mà
đúng không? Các cái mô hình LM các bạn
không dùng những cái mô hình thông qua
API các bạn tự host. Các bạn tự host thì
dữ liệu nó cũng không bay ra ngoài đúng
không? Vẫn đúng không? Nên khi mà các
bạn tự host những mô hình đấy thì các
bạn cũng các bạn cũng đâu cần phải học
gì AI này đâu.
Tiết kiệm chi phí là một lý do. Đúng.
Tiết kiệm chi phí là một lý do. Còn lý
do gì nữa?
Có phải là dữ liệu nó càng ngày nó càng
có nhiều cây mới và có những cái mà nó
sẽ bị lỗi thời hay là
nên là mình phải từ lúc nào phải huấn
luyện mô hình hay
>> mình cũng có thể huấn luyện các cái mô
hình mình cho các cái mô hình LM người
ta người ta không gọi là huấn luyện cái
đâu là f tune người ta hoàn toàn có thể
f tune lm tức là có cái dữ liệu mình
file tun nó vào để cho cái mình cái lm
nó có thể nó biết thêm cái rượu mới này
thì với mm nó cũng được th sao mình
không dùng luôn những cái mô hình rất là
xị sòi rồi mình phải tự đi ngồi làm
những cái mô hình khác làm gì tại vì
hàng ngày đều ngày dư mới không không
tất nhiên là f tool l nó sẽ không dễ
dàng như file to tun nhện mô hình bé bé
này nhưng mà đấy cũng ok cũng có thể coi
lại một lý do đi muốn cái chân hóa này
được phụ có yêu cầu
muốn cá nhân hóa thì vẫn có thể dùng
được mà iun lm prom engineering vẫn có
thể làm được mà
bảo mật không bảo mật như mình vừa nói
mình có thể là mình tự host những cái mô
hình trên máy của mình tự host các bạn
dùng olama các bạn dùng vi các bạn tự
host được À
anh nghĩ là vẫn cần phải có cái nguồn
nhân lực mới vì càng ngay cái thế hệ cũ
thì càng ra đi thì phải có lớp người trẻ
để mà học cái đấy. [hắng giọng]
>> Cũng cũng là một lý do. Cũng là một lý
do cũng là một lý do. Đấy là một lý do
đúng. Thế nhưng mà những cái người mà
thực sự vào những cái công ty này để họ
thực sự họ thiết kế những mô hình này
thì số này nó rất là nhỏ so với số lượng
người khủng rất là lớn để học ngày nay.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Lý do này có rất có lý
do thì có rất là nhiều thôi. Thế nhưng
mà chúng ta có chúng ta có một vài những
cái lý do chính lý do đầu cái lý do đầu
tiên như các bạn đã nói rồi đúng không?
Những cái thứ liên quan đến dữ liệu và
eo đặc thù đúng không?
Những cái bài toán của doanh nghiệp đúng
không? Cái bài toán của doanh nghiệp
nhiều khi nó rất là đặc thù, nó rất là
đặc biệt. Thế nếu mà chúng ta chúng ta
cứ táng thẳng cái dữ liệu đó vào trong
các cái mô hình ngữ lớn mà chúng ta
không có một cái điều chỉnh gì cả thì
chúng ta sẽ ra những kết quả nó không có
tốt đúng không? Kết quả nó sẽ không có
tốt. Đấy là cái lý do thứ nhất. Cái lý
do thứ hai nữa là gì? Đó là cái lý do
liên quan đến việc là chi phí như các
bạn vừa nói ấy đúng không? Các bạn hiểu
này. Cái mục đích của các ông lớn như là
Open AI, ờ Google hay là Meta khi mà họ
cho ra mắt các cái mô hình các cái công
cụ AI như kiểu chat GBT, GI Dipsic hoặc
là close á đúng không? Mục đích chính
của họ là gì? là để đảm bảo rằng
bất kể người dùng có cái background, có
cái nhu cầu, có cái sự quan tâm đến cái
đến cái gì nữa thì các công cụ ấy này nó
vẫn trải được đúng không? Bất kể người
hỏi là nam hay là nữ, già hay là trẻ,
làm giáo viên, làm kỹ sư, làm bác sĩ hay
là ai, tức là hỏi cái gì nó cũng chảy
được đúng không? Bất kể là người hỏi là
ai. Thế để có được cái khả năng này thì
các cái mô hình hố ng lớn các bạn thấy
là nó đều có kích thức rất là lớn, đúng
không? Các môn người lớn nó đều phải có
đến hàng tỷ, hàng chục tỷ tham số nó rất
là lớn và để chạy nó thì cũng cần phải
những cái cơ sở hạ tầng rất là lớn nữa
đúng không? Thế nhờ vậy nên là nó có thể
trả lời được mọi thứ đúng không? Nó có
như kiểu là trên thông thên văn, giữa
tương địa lý. Thế nhưng mà vấn đề là sau
này khi mà các bạn đi làm ở doanh nghiệp
thì các bạn sẽ thường xuyên gặp cái bài
toán là gì? Là tôi không cần phải một
cái mô hình biết làm văn, làm thơ, làm
toán. Tôi chỉ cần một cái mô hình, ví dụ
một cái mô hình nó chỉ làm sao nó có thể
dự án được xem là một cái giao dịch có
phải dịch lừa đảo hay không. hay là một
mô hình mình dự đoán được xem là doanh
số doanh thu trong tháng tới là bao
nhiêu. Tức là gì? Tôi không cần nó phải
biết làm 100 bài toán. Tôi chỉ cần nó
biết làm một bài toán thôi. Nhưng mà tờ
đấy nó làm nó phải tốt và với chi phí nó
phải rẻ đúng không? Thì bây gi các bạn
cứ tưởng tượng là bây giờ mà các bạn
dùng chat liên tục đúng không? Có thể là
các bạn dùng chatt các bạn thể dùng API
API nó sẽ tốn tiền đúng không? Nó tốn
rất là nhiều tiền. Thế nó sẽ không có
kinh tế một chút nào đúng không? Và các
bạn nghĩ vào xem chúng ta dùng cái mô
hình mà nó biết làm văn, làm thơ, làm
toán mà chúng ta lại chỉ muôn đời chúng
ta chỉ hỏi nó đúng cái câu về
dự đoán doanh số doanh thu thôi đúng
không? Thì chúng ta sẽ rất là lãng phí
cái tài nguyên của nó đúng không? Tôi
không cần cái mô hình vài tỷ tham số thì
tôi làm cái việc đấy. Tôi chỉ một một
cái mô hình vài nghìn hoặc thí là vài
trăm nghìn tham số là đã đủ rồi đúng
không? Thế nên ấy những cái công cụ như
chatt ấ nó chỉ có cái nó có cái tác dụng
là gì? là
khiến a đưa đem AI đến gần người dùng
phổ thông hơn đúng không? Và có thể làm
được các cái tác vụ tổng quát rất là
tốt. Thế nhưng mà khi mà chúng ta biết
chắc rằng là chúng ta chỉ phải làm một
cái việc cụ thể thôi thì dùng cái mô
hình nhỏ nhẹ nghe mô hình truyền thống
nó sẽ tốt hơn và nó sẽ tối ưu hóa với
bạn chi phí hơn rất là nhiều so với việc
các bạn dùng mô hình môn ngự lớn đúng
không? Mô hình ngự lớn nó không phải là
nó không phải là everything đâu. Ví dụ
bây giờ các bạn muốn xây dựng cái ứng
dụng làm sao có thể theo dõi quan sát
xem ở là ở ngoài giao ngoài giao thông
ấy có xe vượt đèn đỏ hay không. Nếu có
thì ghi lại biển số ấy đúng không? Bây
giờ các bạn cứ thấy tưởng tượng là bây
giờ có một cái camera nó thu khung hình
đúng không? Cứ mỗi một giây ví dụ camera
nó thu 2 năm khung hình đi đúng không?
Còn bây giờ cái mốt một khung hình nó
thu nó lại gửi và chat gpt ấy thì cái
chi phí các bạn chạy một ngày nó rất là
tốn luôn rất là tốn và các bạn sẽ không
thể nào các bạn chạy thời gian thực
được. Thế thì các bạn cứ tưởng tượng các
bạn hỏi chatt ý các bạn hỏi nó câu 1 bằ
ha thôi nó cũng phải ngồi tính một lúc
đúng không? Thì bây giờ các bạn muốn
chạy thă thực chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì
bây giờ 1 giây các bạn phải xử lý được 2
năm khung hình. Thế bây giờ 2 năm khung
hình các bạn dùng mô hình to như kiểu
cht thì làm sao mà xử lý được. Mặc dù là
nó có thể đúng đấy nhưng mà nó sẽ nó nó
sẽ không đủ nhanh để chúng ta có thể
triển khai trong thực tế đúng không? Mà
nếu mà không triển khai được thì việc nó
đúng thì cũng chả thể làm gì cả đúng
không? Một cái mô hình nó chỉ thực sự
với nghĩa khi nó có thể triển khai khách
hàng có thể sử dụng được đúng không? Đạo
giá trị chứ còn nếu mà nó rất là đúng
nhưng mà nó lại rất là chậm thì cũng chả
có ai dùng được nó cả đúng không? Cái
đấy là những cái lý do mà vì sao mà đã
có những cái công cụ mà như chatbt rồi
chúng ta vẫn cứ phải đi học truyền thống
là vì như vậy đúng không?
Như bọn mình là công ty thực tế thì bọn
mình cũng dùng chvity các thứ để là hỗ
trợ quá trình code thôi chứ còn cái sản
phẩm của mình bọn mình không thể nào mà
bọn mình dùng các m ngô ng để thay thế
được tại vì chúng nó tốn tiền quá nặng
quá thiết bị của mình nó tài nguyên phần
cứng nó hạn chế thôi không dùng những
cái mô hình đấy được dùng một mô hình
đấy thôi là nó tự nó còn nặng hơn cả cái
pipeline của bọn mình rồi đấ
>> Việt ơi Việt ơi cho mình hỏi tại vì mình
chưa hiểu ý sâu xa 100% ở cái câu này
của Việt là mình đào tạo huấn luyện mô
hình là mô hình mô hình của tự mình hay
là mình ờ huấn luyện mô hình của bọn ZVT
hay Zuấn luyện mô hình của mình tức là à
mình tạo ra riêng một mô hình của mình
mà mình tự không phải mình tạo ra mô
hình tức là gì tức là có những cái mô
hình machining truyền thống nó không nó
không nặng nề như chat TV CVT nó chỉ mô
hình nó có thể vài chục vài trăm vài
nghìn tham số thôi mình sẽ huấn luyện
những cái mô hình đấy chứ mình không hỗn
luyện những cái mô hình to như này
chatbt mô hình to này
>> mô hình đấy là của của của bên nào hay
là mình
>> có rất là nhiều bên nó những cái mô hình
mà ví dụ từ ngày xưởng ngày xưa là người
ta đã ra những cái thuật toán đấy rồi
thì bây có những cái thư viện người ta
đã tích hợp ra những cái những cái mô
hình đấy rồi mình chỉ mình gọi ra thôi.
>> Nhưng ví dụ như là hôm nay mình có mình
mình cũng có thử một cái cái mô hình của
Zemma 4 mới có không ZMA này nó vẫn là
ngôn ngữ lớn rồi em
>> nó cũng là một cái ngôn ngữ lớn.
>> Vâng nó là ngôn ngữ lớn rồi. Nó con đấy
là nó không phải nó là không phẩy mấy tỷ
tham số nh nó là ngôn ngữ lớn rồi. Ngôn
ngữ lớn rồi.
Những cái mô hình em nói đây là những
cái mô hình mà nó không phải mô hình
cũng lớn và những mô hình m chiến thống.
Cái gì là mô chuyên đế thống thì trong
những buổi sau chúng ta học đến thì mình
sẽ đi qua từng cái một.
>> À cái gì cái gì buổi sau mình sẽ biết
đúng.
>> Vâng đúng rồi. Cái mô hình truyền thống
này rất là bé thôi. Nó chỉ có vài vài
chục vài trăm vài nghìn tham số mà
>> nó giống kiểu như là mình hiện tại mình
chỉ học những phép toán cộng trừ nhân
chia bình thường thôi chứ mình chưa thể
nào giải những bài toán giải tích hoặc
là các các kiểu được luôn. Cũng có thể
nói là như vậy.
>> Có thể nói là như vậy. Thật ra
>> thật ra các cái môi ngôn các cái muôi
ngôn ngữ lớn ấy nó cũng chỉ xây dựng dựa
trên phép cộng với phép nhân thôi. Hôm
nay em cũng chỉ cộng với nhân có thể
thêm cả phép lũy thừa nữa nhưng mà chủ
yếu là cộng với nhân. Thật ra các môn
muôn lớn chúng ta dùng ấy cái việc chúng
ta đưa dữ liệu vào cho mô hình ấy dữ
liệu nó là một đầu. Mô hình là một đầu
thì cái việc tương tác giữa dữ liệu với
mô hình ấ nó không khác gì cái việc là
chúng ta nhân hai ma trận vào đấy nhá.
Dữ liệu chúng ta sẽ số hóa thành ma
trận. Cái mô hình ở bên trong cái tham
số nó cũng là một cái ma trận. Hai ông
tương tác nhau chính là nhân ma trận.
Ok.
Anh có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Rồi. Ok.
Có lẽ chúng ta nghỉ ra 5 phút các bạn
nhá. Nghỉ ra 5 phút chúng ta học tiếp
nhá. Má nghe mấy này
>> mà. Các bạn có câu hỏi gì bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá.
Mình sẽ đọc à đọc báo một chút
có gì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
>> Dạ. Alo. Cho em hỏi một chút.
>> À dạ cho em hỏi là về cái áp dụng
machine learning trong cái quản trị rủi
ro cái risk control á anh.
>> Thì anh có thể chia sẻ một chút cái kiến
thức kinh nghiệm của anh về cái lĩnh vực
đó thôi. Được không ạ?
>> À ok nhá. Thế ví dụ mình muốn cảm chị lý
do t này tức là ví dụ mình mình có thể
xây một cái mô hình để làm sao để dựa
cái thông tin đầu vào là ví dụ là một
cái dự án hay là một cái cái một cái dự
án hoặc là một cái việc gì mình đang
mình đang muốn làm đúng không? Và mình
muốn đánh giá xem là cái mức độ rủi ro
của cái dự án này hoặc là mức độ rủi ro
của cái việc người ta muốn làm nó là bao
nhiêu đúng không? Thì mình có thể là
mình sẽ dựa vào những cái những cái dự
án chúng ta đã hiện trong quá khứ rồi.
Chúng ta đánh giá xem cái mức độ thành
công của nó. Đ mình sẽ huấn luyện một
cái mô hình để làm sao nó dựa vào những
cái thứ nó đã học những cái thứ trong
quá khứ đấy để trong tương lai nếu mình
có một cái dự án nó mình sẽ đánh giá xem
là cái mức độ tiềm năng của cái dự này
nó như nào nó có cái rủi ro gì hay
không. Đấy là một ví dụ tức là huấn
luyện mô hình dựa vào những thứ đã học
trong quá những cái thứ đã xảy ra trong
quá khứ để trong tương lai nó sẽ đánh
giá những cái thứ tương tự. Đấy nó cũng
giống như kiểu là lúc chúng ta đi học
chúng ta chúng ta học tính đạo hàm tích
phân để lúc chúng ta đi thi chúng ta sẽ
làm những câu đạo hàm tích phân mà cái
đề bài nó mới nó mới tinh đúng chúng ta
chưa làm câu đấy bao giờ nhưng mà chúng
ta vẫn biết làm. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó
cũng là đào tích phân. Ngày xưa chúng ta
học cái thứ đấy rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
muốn mô hình làm được cái gì thì chúng
ta phải huấn luyện nó với cái dữ liệu
liên quan đến cái đấy.
À data engineer và data khác nhau như
nào các bạn chú ý nhá. Thì trong cái
mảng data ấy có ba cái job liên quan đến
có ba cái job có chữ data mà hay đi cùng
với nhau. Một là data engineer, hai là
data analyst và ba là data scientist.
Thì cái sự khác biệt giữa ba cái mảng
này nó là cái gì? Thì đầu tiên là về
data. Data là những người người ta sẽ
phụ trách, người ta xây dựng những cái
cơ sở dữ liệu, những cái người ta gọi là
data warehouse, tức là cái nơi để có thể
để lưu trữ dữ liệu đấy đúng không? Phải
có cái đấy thì những cái người khác như
là data scientist, data analyst họ mới
có thể truy cập và họ họ họ họ họ họ lấy
dữ liệu được đúng không? Thì data là cái
người mà họ sẽ xây dựng cái gọi là cái
cơ sở hạ tầng đi. Cơ sở hạ tầng về mặt
dữ liệu. Thế [khịt mũi] thế còn sau
chúng ta sẽ có hai cái row mà sẽ sử dụng
cái dữ liệu này là data data analyst và
data scientist. Hai cái này cách mà họ
truy cập vào thường họ sẽ dùng SQL đúng
không? Họ thường sẽ dùng SQL để họ có
thể truy cập vào họ đánh cái rượu cần
thiết. Nhưng cái sự khác biệt giữa hai
cái row này là cái gì? Với cái row data
data analyst ấy thì họ sẽ tập trung vào
việc là họ sẽ sử dụng dữ liệu để phân
tích những cái thứ đã xảy ra rồi. Ví dụ
họ xây dựng lên những cái dashboard đúng
không? Họ có thể dùng TLW hoặc là Power
BI để họ dự cái lên cái dashboard để có
thể phân tích thêm là doanh số doanh thu
của 3 tháng vừa rồi là là như thế nào
đúng không? Công ty mà lãi hay lỗ thì
nguyên do là nguyên do là vì sao? Tức là
họ sẽ sử dụng họ sẽ khai thác dữ liệu để
có thể phân tích những thứ nó đã xả rồi.
Thế còn data scientist là những người sẽ
dựa vào dữ liệu để có thể huấn luyện
những cái mô hình để dự đoán những cái
thứ sẽ xảy ra đúng không? Data analy tập
trung vào quá khứ và hiện tại. Còn data
sàn test tập trung vào tương lai. Ví dụ
các bạn sẽ được cái mô hình để dự đoán
xem là doanh số hay là doanh thu của 3
tháng tới là như thế nào. Hoặc bạn dự án
xem là cái tháng tới thì cái trend nó là
cái gì đấy đúng không? Đấy thì tức là
đều là dùng dữ liệu nhưng một ông thì
đánh giá những cái thứ đã xảy ra và một
ông thì dự đoán những cái thứ mà sẽ xảy
ra trong tương lai. Thì hai cái nó đều
quan trọng cả. Một công ty, một doanh
nghiệp mà muốn phát triển thì họ không
chỉ dựa vào cái việc là tôi dự đoán
trước là tháng tới có cái gì mà họ còn
phải biết là cách rút kinh nghiệm từ
những thứ nó đã xả ra rồi đúng không?
Thế nên là họ cần phải có cả những cái
như là data analyst đúng không? để phân
tích cái thứ đã đã xong rồi để có gì rút
kinh nghiệm và data cent để dự đoán
những cái thứ sẽ xảy ra để tôi có thể
tôi lường trước xem là xu hướng thị
trường nó như thế nào. Đấy thì đây là
cái sự khác biệt giữa data engineer là
tạo ra dữ liệu còn data và data sùng dữ
liệu đó để phân tích quá khứ và dự án
tương lai
nhá. Ai câu hỏi thì các bạn cứ hỏi tiếp
nhá. Mình vẫn mình vẫn nhìn đoạn chat
của các bạn nhá.
Có chứ. Đây là nội dung của khóa này mà
nó là nội dung của khóa này mà mình
không phải là mình chỉ dạy các bạn gọi
thư viện ra đâu. Nó là nội dung chính
của khóa này đấy.
Chúng ta sẽ không code s from squad tại
vì code này nó rất là tốn thời gian. Đó
nó cũng không có ích lợi gì cả. Chúng ta
sẽ học tìm hiểu về lý thuyết về các cái
mô hình về các cái kiến trúc trong về
các cái thuật toán trong machining. Thế
nhưng mà sau khi chúng ta hiểu kiến trúc
rồi chúng ta sẽ gọi thư viện thôi. Chứ
còn nếu các bạn muốn code from squad thì
có ghi cảm khóa cũng chỉ đổ chung một
toán thôi. Và cái việc code form s nó
chả chả tác dụng gì cả. Tốn thời gian
thôi nó không tác tác dụng gì cả.
Thông thường những người mà bảo là code
form squad ấy họ cũng đều là họ nhìn cái
tutorial code nào các bạn người ta code
y chang lại như vậy đến cuối đến cuối
gọi là code form squad mà chúng đều là
theo cái tutorial đấy mà chúng ta cũng
đâu có tự làm cái gì đâu
>> anh ơi. Ừ.
>> Anh cho em hỏi là lúc mà anh làm
engineer á anh
>> ừ
>> thì cái công đoạn nào trong quá trình mà
anh làm thì nó sẽ phải tốn nhiều thời
gian nhất? Ví dụ như là xử lý data hay
là tối tham số hay là phải thanh chỉnh
mô hình ấ
>> data cái thứ nhất là data. Thứ nhất là
data tức là chuẩn bị dữ liệu. Chuẩn bị
dữ liệu đó là bao gồm cả đánh hãn dữ
liệu này, đánh đánh giá dữ liệu này,
tiền sữ dữ liệu này. Và cái nữa là model
deployment là triển khai mô hình. Thế
còn cái đoạn mà thật ra cái đoạn cái
đoạn mà các bạn thường hay học trên
trường đại học ấ huấn luyện mô hình các
thứ nó rất là nhanh tại vì bây giờ các
thứ nó đều open shot hết rồi một cái nút
enter là xong rất là nhanh nhưng mà làm
sao để tôi có thể tôi có được cái dữ
liệu phù hợp tôi đánh nhãn dữ liệu v làm
sao tôi có thể tôi triển khai nó để sao
khách hàng sử dụng được nó là cái tốn
thời gian hơn
[khịt mũi]
>> em cảm ơn anh
>> ừ
ui em có ba chan tran vào đủ rồi em em
có ba chan trở đủ rồi không cần cài thêm
cái gì nữa.
W X1 X1 là
nó là X đúng không? X nó là cái input
đầu vào. Tham số WB là những cái thứ là
thuộc về nội tại của mô hình. Đấy X là
cái dệ vào. X em tưởng tượng nó giống
như kiểu là sách vở em học ấy. Còn WB nó
chính là cái nội tại của em đấy. B à B B
B B B là gì? B là bi b nó giống như kiểu
cái hàm y = x + b ấy. B nó là cái hạng
tử tự do đấy. Thì thì trong cái a thì
thì trong cái a trong cái công thức wx +
b kia thì b nó cũng y như vậy.
Ai thông thường camera thường và camera
có ai ấ tức là người ta đã tích hợp một
vài những cái giải pháp đơn giản trong
cái AI đó. Ví dụ là giải pháp đếm người
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy, tức là cái
camera ấy đã tích hợp một vài những giải
pháp AI ở ở bên trong rồi. Còn camera
còn camera bình thường là nó chỉ có mỗi
chức năng thu hình ảnh thôi. Đấy cái sự
khác biệt chỉ là một ông là chỉ thu hình
ảnh còn một ông là thu hình ảnh kết hợp
với có một vài giải pháp tích hợp sẵn.
Thế thôi.
Được chưa? Thì được chưa? Sao lại không?
Được chưa?
Có dataing hay người ta gọi là data
annotation là đánh nhẵn dữ liệu. Đây một
cái job. Nhưng job này thường dành cho
các bạn là sinh viên. Thường các công ty
đánh nhá dữ liệu thường thọ thuê sinh
viên tại vì là sinh viên giá nó rẻ. Cái
công vự này thì th các bạn chẳng cần
kiến thức chuyên môn gì cả. Các bạn nh
có mắt có mũi có tay là các bạn làm được
rồi. Cả nó rất là dễ nó không đỏ kế thức
chuyên môn nhưng mà nó cũng khá là nhàm
chán và lương thì thường rất là thấp.
Các cái nước ở như Việt Nam Ấn Độ với
các nước châu Phi thì cái mảng data
annotation này rất là rất là phát triển
là chi phí nó rẻ.
Ngày xưa á, ngày xưa cái job trước của
mình á, cái job mà mình làm ở hồi 2021
đây này. Hồi mà vừa hết Covid ấy, cái
job này này, cái job đây này mình làm từ
tháng 4 2021 đến tháng 9 2022 ấy. Cái
job này hồi mình vào công ty ấ cái task
đầu tiên mà xế ra cho mình là gì? Là tìm
một công ty ở Việt Nam làm về mảng data
annotation.
Tìm một công ty ở Việt Nam làm về mảng
data annotation tại vì bên này mình chi
bị giá rẻ.
Ok, thôi tiếp các bạn nhá. Em đủ rồi
nhá. Tiếp nhá. Thì bây giờ chúng ta nói
về một vài những cái lý do là vì sao mà
bây giờ A nó rất là phát triển rồi chúng
tôi vẫn phải học AI, vẫn phải học
machining. Thế tại vì là rất nhiều
trường hợp các bạn sẽ không thể sử dụng
những cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn kia tại
nó quá là tốn kém, nó quá là cồng kềnh,
chúng ta cần có những cái mô hình nhỏ
hơn. nó làm việc nó chỉ làm việc tốt với
một bài toán thôi nhưng mà đấy là bài
toán mà chúng ta cần và nó sẽ làm việc
với chi phí tối thiểu không? Đấy tiếp
này. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau ờ
nói về tổng quan các cái khái niệm
quan trọng mà các bạn cần phải nắm được
nhá. Một vài những cái khái niệm quan
trọng mà các bạn cần phải nắm được. Ờ
chờ đến mình chờ đ mình thu cái khay này
xuống
các bạn nhìn nhá.
Ở đây chúng ta có hai cái sơ đồ ven đúng
không? Sơ đồ ven ngày xưa lớp 6 các bạn
học rồi đúng không? Học về số nguyên, số
thực các thứ ấy đúng không? Đây các bạn
có hai cái hai cái ven diagram đúng
không? Thì b các bạn [khịt mũi] sẽ tập
trung nhìn mình vào cái sơ đồ ven ở phía
bên trái trước nhá. Thì sơ đồ ven ở phía
bên trái ấ chúng ta có năm cái vòng tròn
đúng không? Vòng tròn về computer
science, vòng tròn về AI, vòng tròn về
machining, vòng tròn về deing và vòng
tròn về data sense nhá. Thì bây gi chúng
ta sẽ tập trung vào cái vào cái sơ đồ
ven này trước. Cái sơ đồ ven kia trực
tiếp tế chúng ta sẽ nói sẽ nói sau. Thì
các bạn nhìn này, bây gi chúng ta sẽ
cùng nhau đi qua các cái khái niệm nhá.
Đầu tiên là computer sense. Computer
sense là khoa máy tính. Nhưng mà ở đây
có một cái điểm các bạn nhá. Ở đây có
một cái điểm là đối với thế giới ấy cái
từ này nó là computer sense.
Nhưng mà về Việt Nam ấy cái thứ mà chúng
ta cái thứ ở Việt Nam mà tương đương với
camion ấy nó không phải là khoa học máy
tính đâu. Cái thứ ở Việt Nam mà tương
đương với Camon ấy nó là công nghệ thông
tin.
Việt Nam mình dùng hai cái từ computer
sense và information technology nó ngược
so với thế giới.
Ở thế giới á thì computation science là
cái mảng lớn
ở thế giới ấ computer s là cái mảng lớn
bên trong camera san có nhiều mảng con
và một trong số cái mảng con đấy là
information technology.
Thế nhưng mà riêng Việt Nam mình Việt
Nam mình chắc là cái lớp chắc là cái
nước duy nhất trên thế giới dùng ngược
lại là gì? là công nghệ thông tin là cái
mảng lớn. Bên trong công nghệ thông tin
thì lại có một cái mảng con là computer
silence.
Thế nên á nếu các bạn đi ra nước ngoài
mà các bạn giới thiệu là các bạn là sinh
viên công nguyện thông tin ấy thì các
bạn đừng có nói là I'm an IT student.
Nếu các bạn bảo với người ta là I'm an
IT student là các bạn đang thu hẹp cái
mảng của bạn mà các bạn phải nói là tôi
là CS student, tôi là cam student. Các
bạn nhớ nhá. Cái từ camer sant Việt Nam
mình nó dùng không dùng thế giới đâu. Nó
dùng không dùng thế giới đâu. Ở Việt Nam
mình là công nghệ thông tin là cái to
còn thế là comp nó mới là cái to đúng
không? Các bạn ra ngoài các bạn tất cả
các bạn các bạn bất kể các bạn làm web
về web về game về app gì các bạn cứ bảo
tôi là CS student đúng không? Tôi là cái
ông trong cái lĩnh vực lớn chứ không
phải là tôi không phải là cái ông trong
lĩnh vực nhỏ đúng không? Đấy thế nhá.
Thì cái từ cam ở đây mình đang dùng ý
nghĩa của thế giới. Thế còn nếu mà về
Việt Nam các bạn thay nó bằng cái từ
công nghệ thông tin cho mình nhá. Được
chưa? Thế và khi mà các bạn bảo mình là
các bạn sinh viên công nghệ ông tin thì
mình sẽ hiểu các bạn là CS student. Ok.
Ví dụ Harvard có cái khóa CS50 ấy, CS50
ấy. Đấy là dành cho những ông học công
nghệ thông tin đấy chứ không phải là
dành cho những ông nào học về mỗi khoa
học máy tính đâu. Đấy Việt Nam mình nó
nó nó phân theo kiểu nó chả giống ai cả.
Thì các bạn chú ý đoạn đấy nhá. Được
chưa? Các cái trường đại học cũng là
công nhận tin là cái khoa to bình so với
trong mình có kho máy tính mà nó không
phải như vậy thì nó không có đúng.
Đấy. Thế bây giờ bên trong camera sence
hay là bên trong công nghệ thông tin ở
Việt Nam đúng không? Chúng ta bắt đầu có
cái lĩnh vực con là lĩnh vực AI. Lĩnh
vực AI. Thế thì AI có rất nhiều cái định
nghĩa khác nhau về AI. Hàn Lâm học thật
cũng có, dễ hiểu cũng có nhưng mà các
bạn hiểu biết đơn giản là gì? AI là
chúng ta làm sao chúng ta khiến cho máy
móc có thể làm những công việc thay thế
cho con người nhá. Chúng ta cứ làm cái
gì làm cho máy nó thể thay cho con người
thì đấy người ta gọi là AI rồi. Đấy
người ta gọi là AI rồi. Thế ờ có một cái
điểm như này đó là thông thường á thông
thường chúng ta thường hay bị nhất là
những người ngoài ngành nhất là những
người ngoà người ta thường người ta hay
bị ảnh hưởng bởi những cái bộ phim
Hollywood hoặc là người ta bị ảnh hưởng
bởi những cái công cụ như là chat GVT
người ta cứ nghĩ là AI nó phải là cái gì
nó rất là cao siêu, rất là kinh khủng.
Ví dụ cái thời ngày xưa ấ mọi người xem
phim Hollywood mọi người thấy là có
những con robot nó có thể đi lại nó cử
động giống như con người. Người ta nghĩ
là AI ảnh này là như thế. Hoặc là ngày
xưa bọn Nhật Bản Nhật Bản là họ cái con
robot asimo ấy đúng không? Là cứ vẻ
người đi lại như con người, cử động như
con người thì mới là AI. Ho bây giờ bạn
ấy có những công cụ như kiểu chat GVT
người ta cứ nghĩ là phải là chat GVT
phải là LOM thì nó mới là AI. Nhưng mà
thật ra đấy nó không đúng. AI nó cũng
giống như là bất kỳ một cái mảng con nào
khác trong công ty cũng thế thôi. Ví dụ
như web nhá. Các bạn sử dụng cái trang
web
như kiểu là VN Express ấy đúng không? Nó
là trang web các bạn. Một cái x cái
trang web nó chỉ chạy local, nó chỉ in
ra được mỗi một cái dòng chữ Hello
World, chữ đen nền trắng nó cũng là
trang web. Các bạn làm một cái game như
kiểu là Liên Minh Huyền thoại hoặc là
Dota nó là game. Các bạn làm một cái
game như kiểu là Flappy Bird ấy, nó chỉ
là game 8 bit thôi, nó cũng cứ là game.
Thì AI nó cũng như thế. AI nó không phải
nó chỉ có những cái thứ cao siêu mà nó
có những thứ rất là cơ bản. Thế thế ví
dụ các bạn làm được một cái game, các
bạn làm được một con con boss, nó có thể
chơi game kéo lá lá đấm giống với với cả
người thì đó cũng là ai rồi. Tại vì bình
thường là chơi kéo lá đấm là các bạn
phải có hai người. Bây giờ các bạn tạo
ra con chat thì các bạn chỉ một người
thôi thì rõ ràng con chat này nó làm
thay công việc của con người mặc dù là
cái logic nó rất là đơn giản đúng không?
Thế đó cũng là AI rồi. Đó là ai rồi.
Trong quá trình mà mình tham gia các cái
group trên Facebook ấy mình đã từng rất
là vất vả để mình và sau này mình nhận
mình nhận mình nhận ra là mình không nên
giải thích làm cái gì. Tức là có rất
nhiều người người ta nghĩ là cứ phải là
kiểu chat GBT các thứ thì mới là AI. Còn
những kiểu cái mô hình ví dụ nhận diện
đối tượng các thứ hoặc là nhận diện chữ
viết chẳng hạn thì người ta không coi là
AI. Nhưng mà không phải như vậy. AI nó
cũng có đầu từ những thứ rất là bình
thường. Thế khi mà các bạn học về các
bạn sẽ biết là à AI không chỉ có chat
TVT, không chỉ có LM, không chỉ có AI
agent còn có rất nhiều từ khác nữa. Đấy,
cứ về mặt nguyên tắc, cứ cái gì mà các
bạn có thể làm, các bạn tạo ra cái cỗ
máy một con chot nó thay thế công việc
của con người đó đã là AI rồi đúng
không? Kể cả thay thế công việc chân tay
nó cũng là AI rồi. Nhưng mà tất nhiên có
một cái điều là gì? Đó là càng ngày AI
nó càng phát triển nên là cái kỳ vọng
của mọi người, kỳ vọng của phần đông mọi
người về AI nó càng cao hơn. Mọi người
càng ngày mọi người càng kỳ vọng là AI
phải những gì nó rất là cao siêu. Nhưng
mà thật ra về mặt bản chất nó không phải
như vậy. AI nó cũng chỉ như bất kỳ một
cái mảng nào khác thôi. Web, game, app,
mạng đúng không? Nó bao gồm cả những cái
thứ đơn giản và cả những thứ phức tạp
chứ không phải là chỉ có toàn robot với
cả chat GBT. Đấy, thì đấy là về AI.
Thế thì bên trong AI ấy chúng ta có một
cái vòng tròn con là về machining.
AI là mảng con của công nghệ thông tin
còn machining là mảng con của AI.
Machining là tập hợp của những cái thuật
toán mà chúng ta sẽ sử dụng để chúng ta
có thể ờ khiến cho máy móc có thể làm
thay công việc cho con người mà chúng ta
sẽ không cần phải huấn luyện chúng một
cách tường minh. Cái sự khác biệt giữa
machining và AI nằm ở cái chữ tường minh
này. Với machine learning chúng ta có
thể huấn luyện cái mô hình mà không cần
phải chỉ ra một cách tường minh. Thế bây
giờ mình sẽ chỉ các bạn một cái ví dụ để
các bạn thấy được sự khác biệt giữa AI
và machining. Tất nhiên các bạn nhìn
thấy này, machining là một cái vòng tròn
con của con của AI có nghĩa là gì? Có
nghĩa là cái gì mà đã làm machining thì
nó
làm sao các bạn nhỉ? Cái gì nó đã làm
machine thì nó cũng làm sao?
Cái gì nó đã làm
>> à đúng rồi, nó cũng là AI đúng không?
Cái gì mà machining thì nó cũng auto nó
là AI nhưng là AI thì chưa chắc đã là
machining. Nó cũng giống như kiểu gì?
Một số nó đã là số tự nhiên thì chắc
chắn nó phải là số nguyên đúng không?
Nhưng nó là số nguyên chưa chắc là số tự
nhiên đúng không? Tự nhiên là 0, 2 3 4 5
còn có số nguyên là cả bắt đầu số âm nữa
đúng không? Số tự nhiên là tập con của
số nguyên nên là đã là tự nhiên thì nó
sẽ phải là nguyên nhưng mà nguyên thì
trước là tự nhiên. Thì ở đây machin với
ai cũng như vậy. Thế bây giờ cái sự khác
biệt đây đây đây đây cho các bạn ví dụ
ngay đây nhá. Tức là cái sự khác biệt
giữa merchaning và AI ấy nó nằm ở nó nằm
ở cái chữ tường minh. Thế bây giờ nhá
mình cho các bạn một cái ví dụ để các
bạn thấy xem là lập trình tường minh và
lập trình không tường minh nó khác nhau
như thế nào. Thế bây giờ ví dụ này. Ví
dụ bây giờ nhá mình đang ví dụ mình làm
đang làm trong lĩnh vực ngân hàng làm
trong banking được chưa? Bây giờ mình
muốn là gì? Mình muốn là bây giờ mình
muốn xây dựng cái mô hình để làm sao?
Một con chatbot đi. Cái mô hình con
chatbot một cái gì đấy đúng không? mình
muốn một cái gì đấy để nó giúp mình làm
sao để cái sau này mình đưa vào đồ vào
là những cái thông tin về một cái gia
ngân hàng nào đó mà cái đồ ra cái mô
hình hay là cái chatbot hay là cái thứ
này nó sẽ phải đưa ra cho mình cái dự
đoán xem là cái input đồ vào này là một
cái giao dịch bình thường hay đây là một
giao dịch lừa đảo. Được chưa? Input đồ
vào là tất cả thông tin về một giao dịch
ngân hàng và output đồ ra m chỉ ra đây
là giao dịch bình thường hay đây là giao
dịch lừa đải. Được chưa? Sau này các bạn
học nó sẽ là bài toán binary
classification, bài toán phân loại nhị
phân. Đấy mà toán lại là gì? Là bây giờ
các bạn hiểu là chúng ta đang có cái mục
đích như vậy. Thế thế bây giờ chúng ta
sẽ có hai hướng tiếp cận nhá. Chúng ta
sẽ có hai hướng tiếp cận.
Đầu tiên các bạn cho mình hỏi này. Theo
các bạn nhá khi mà các bạn thực hiện một
cái giao dành ngân hàng, các bạn chuyển
khoản tiền từ tài khoản các bạn đến tài
khoản một cái ông A nào đó thì theo các
bạn ở phía ngân hàng họ sẽ có được những
cái thông tin gì? Về cái gia này
theo các bạn họ sẽ có những thông tin
gì?
>> Dạ số tài khoản của người gửi số tả
người nhận
>> à đúng rồi.
>> Thời gian
>> à đúng rồi. Số tài khoản người gửi, số
tài khoản người nhận này. Rồi thời gian
nữa và gì nữa nhở?
>> Địa chỉ, tên, số tiền.
>> Đị chỉ tên à đúng rồi số tiền nữa. Thế
thế là mọi người nhìn nhá. Bây giờ cái
hướng tiếp cận đầu tiên của mình là gì?
là bây giờ mình sẽ định nghĩa ra một bộ
những cái quy tắc, một bộ những cái dấu
hiệu một bộ những cái dấu hiệu thế nào
là giao dịch lừa đảo. Ví dụ bây giờ mình
sẽ có một cái list bao gồm 100 quy tắc,
100 cái dấu hiệu của giao dịch lừa đảo.
Ví dụ quy tắc đầu tiên rule ones là gì?
Là nếu giao dịch được thực hiện ở ngoài
quốc gia mà người đăng mà người gửi đăng
ký. Ví dụ mình đăng ký tài khoản ở Đức,
mình có mình có một cái tài khoản
Postbank của Đức. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ
nó lại phát hiện ra mình có một cái
doanh ngân hàng ở Thụy Sĩ chẳng hạn là
cái điều kiện thứ nhất. Và thứ hai là
gì? Nó vừa được thực hiện ở ngoài cái
quốc gia mình đăng ký. Và thứ hai là cái
số tiền nó quá 100.000 đô đúng không?
Thì nếu mà hai điều kiện này đồng thời
đều thỏa mãn, mình vừa thực hiện giao
dịch ở ngoài quốc gia mình đăng ký tài
khoản và cái số tiền quá 100.000 đô thì
đây được coi là một gia lịch lừa đảo.
Được chưa? Thì đây là cái ru mình sẽ
định nghĩa khoảng thêm khoảng 99 cái ru
nữa đúng không? Dựa vào cái kiến thức
chuyên môn của mình về cái mảng banking
về mảng ngân hàng đúng không? Thế thì
bây giờ sau khi mình đã có một cái list
một cái danh sách bao gồm 100 cái rule
như vậy rồi thì sau này ấ mỗi một cái
danh ngân hàng đến từ tài khoản từ ông A
đến ông B thì cái mô hình cái con
chatbox của chúng ta ấy nó sẽ chỉ đơn
giản gì? Nó sẽ đối chiếu các cái thông
tin của cái gia đó với từng cái rule này
xem là nó có phạm phải cái ru nào không.
Nếu nó phạ phảải bất kỳ một cái ru nào
thì nó sẽ chỉ ra luôn là đây là dịch lừa
đảo. Còn nếu mà nó không phạm vào bất kỳ
một cái ru nào thì nó sẽ coi đây là dịch
bình thường đúng không? Thì cách tiếp
cận này người ta gọi là cách tiếp cận
theo kiểu lập trình tường minh. Vì sao
lại là tường minh? Tại vì các bạn đã chỉ
rõ ra cụ thể là thế nào là lừa đảo rồi
đúng không? Mô hình nó chả phải nghĩ cái
gì cả. Nó không phải suy luận, nó không
phải nghĩ, nó không phải phân tích cái
gì cả. Nó chỉ đơn giản là gì? Là nó đối
chiếu thôi. Đúng nó là ifl chính xác. Nó
là if đến chết đúng không? Nó chỉ if
thôi. Đúng không? nó chỉ out thôi.
Thế thì ý cái cách tiếp cận này ấ người
ta gọi là lập trình tường minh. Tường
minh rất là clear, rất là rõ ràng đúng
không? Everything is clear đúng không?
Thì làm như này ấy thì nó là AI được
chưa? Nó là AI nhưng mà nó không phải là
machining. Nó là AI nhưng mà nó không
phải là machining. Thế machine là như
nào? Thì cách đện thứ hai là như này.
Bây giờ thay vì mình phải ngồi mình bò
ra mình lập ra một cái list có 100 quy
tắc như vậy. Bây giờ mình sẽ làm như
này. Mình sẽ dựa vào những cái giao dịch
trong quá khứ đúng không? Mình đã có một
cái bộ dữ liệu bao gồm rất nhiều cái dây
trong quá khứ. Mỗi một cái giao dịch
mình sẽ có thêm cái thông tin nữa là gì?
Là tức là đã có một ông nào đây có kinh
nghiệm rồi ông đấy chỉ ra là cái gia này
là gia bình thường hay là gia dịch lừa
đảo? Thì mình sẽ có một cái bộ dữ liệu
này bao gồm các cái thông tin về giao
dịch như các bạn vừa nói đúng không?
Người gửi người nhận rồi thời điểm rồi
số tiền. Và chúng ta có thêm một cái cột
nữa một cái thông tin nữa là gì? Là gia
đình này có phải gia lừa đảo hay không?
Đúng không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ dùng cái
bộ rượu này, mình sẽ dùng nó để mình
huấn luyện mô hình. Mình sẽ không chỉ ra
cụ thể là thế nào là lừa đảo mà mình sẽ
đưa cái dựa này vào trong mô hình và mô
hình nó sẽ phải tự nó tìm ra được cái
mối quan hệ, tìm ra được cái
relationship giữa các cái thông tin đồ
vào và cái output đồ ra. Được chưa? Mình
sẽ không chí của chỉ ra mình mà mô hình
nó sẽ phải tự tìm ra cái mối quan hệ
giữa đầu vào với đầu ra như vậy. Thì cái
cách tác luận này ấ người ta gọi là lập
trình cách không tưởng minh đúng không?
Các bạn không hề nói cho mô hình biết
thế nào là lừa đảo mà các bạn chỉ đưa
cho nó một cái bộ dữ liệu bao gồm cả gia
dịch bình thường và gia đình lửa đảo và
mô hình tùy thuộc các cái mô hình khác
nhau. Nó sẽ phải tự tìm cách tìm tìm
được tự tìm được cái mối liên hệ giữa
đầu vào với đầu ra đúng không? Thì cái
này người ta gọi là machine learning.
Được chưa? Cái này người ta gọi là
machine learning. Được chưa? đấy là cái
sự khác biệt giữa
sự khác biệt giữa AI và machining.
Mình cho các bạn thêm một cái ví dụ nữa
nhá. Mình cho các bạn thêm cái ví dụ
nhá. Thế ở cộng đồng này trong cộng đồng
E ở Việt Nam ấy thì nó có bạn Dũng lại
lập trình rất là nổi tiếng đúng không?
Có bạn nào các bạn biết là Dũng lại lập
trình cho mình số 1 xem nào. Bạn nào
không biết cho mình số 0
một này rất là nhiều đúng không? Không
thể thoải có chuyện các bạn biết mình
các bạn vẫn lại không lại không biết
Dũng được đúng không? Ờ thế cái hồi ngày
xưa á cái hồi mà Dũng mới làm cái video
đầu tiên ấy đúng không? Dũng có một cái
video, các bạn nhớ là Dũng có một cái có
một cái video là bạn boss AI mà chơi
game kéo lá đấm ấy đúng không? Từ đấy là
có cái huyền thoại mà đi vào đến chết
đấy đúng không? If computer ra cái gì
người thế này đúng không? Thế các bạn
nhìn này. Hồi đấy là Dũng hay có tức là
Dũng mà sau khi up video xong Dũng sẽ
chia sẻ lên các cái group các thứ thì
Dũng thấy Dũng có năm cái chia sẻ các
cái group về IT. Dũng có ghi là đến đồm
trình chot AI để chơi kéo kéo lá đấm.
Thì ở dưới có rất nhiều bạn comment là
cái gì nhỉ? If e đến chết rồi. Thế này
mà là ai à toàn if với e thôi đúng
không? Thế thì này nếu mà Dũng làm cái
title là gì? Huấn luyện mô hình hoặc là
huấn huấn luyện chbot machining chơi cái
kéo đấm thì là Dũng sai. Cái đấy nó
không phải là machining. Chỉ ra là if I
đấy không phải machining. Thế nhưng mà
Dũng ghi là AI thì hoàn toàn ok. Đấy là
một AI. Thay vì tôi phải chơi hai người,
tôi giờ tôi chỉ có một người chơi với
máy thôi. Cái đấy nó là AI nhưng mà nó
không phải là machining. Đấy thì nếu mà
Dũng ngày xưa mà Dũng dùng cái từ là
machining thì nó hoàn toàn sai nhưng mà
Dũng trong AI thì chả có vấn đề gì cả.
Các bạn chỉ có email thôi, các bạn đã là
AI rồi đấy. Nhưng mà như mình nói tất
nhiên là bây giờ các bạn cũng không thể
nào các bạn có đủ mồm để các bạn đi giải
thích với những người ngoài ngành là gì?
Là à tuy cái này nó đơn giản như nó là
AI đúng không? Không có không chúng ta
không có cái cơ hội đâu đúng không? Thế
nên là với những người ngoà ngành thì
bây giờ càng ngày người ta sẽ càng kỳ
vọng nhiều và AI phải thế này kia. Khi
mà khi mà các bạn học các bạn sẽ biết là
AI nó bao gồm cả những thứ nó rất là cơ
bản, rất là basic nhá. Thì đấy là cái sự
khác biệt giữa AI và machine. Nó chỉ
khác nhau ở cái chữ tường minh thôi đúng
không? Machining là tương tự là lập
trình cách không tường minh đúng không?
Không tường minh, không chỉ ra cụ thể
thế nào thế này thế kia và mô hình nó
phải tự tìm ra cái mối quan hệ đó dựa
trên dữ liệu chúng ta đưa vào.
Rồi
tất nhiên machining nó là cái mảng con
nổi bật nhất của AI. Nổi bật nhất của
AI. Vì sao? Tại vì các bạn hiểu này bây
giờ nhá ví dụ nhá. Vì sao machining nó
lại hiệu quả? Tại vì như này. Các bạn cứ
tưởng tượng mà xem bây giờ nhá. Nếu các
bạn muốn xây dựng một cái mô hình dự
đoán giá nhà đi nhá. Ví dụ như này.
Nhìn nhá. Đây các bạn chờ tí này.
Các bạn cứ tưởng tượng nhá. Bây giờ các
bạn muốn xây dựng cái m hình dữ án giá
nhà đi đúng không? Các bạn cứ nh thông
tin đầu vào là cái gì? Là diện tích của
nhà đúng không? Diện tích này
dài quá đúng không? Diện tích đi đúng
không? Ví dụ diệ tích của nhà là từ từ
10 đến 100 m² đi đúng không? Từ 10 đến
100 m² đúng không các bạn? Bạn thông tin
về số về số tầng đúng không? Nom floor
viết floor nhanh nhá. Đúng không? Tầng
có từ 1 đến 5.
Location vị trí location như là thành
phố đi. City
Việt Nam bây giờ
cứ coi như là có 30 đi nhá. Thôi làm
tròn là 30 đi nhá. Coi như có ba 30
thành phố đi đúng không? Mỗi thành phố
bạn coi như là các bạn có 10 phố đi.
Stet nhá. Các bạn có 10 phố đi đúng
không? Thế đúng không? Rồi mỗi phố các
bạn có thể có nhiều phường viết các thứ
nữa nhưng mà tạm thời như này đi đúng
không? Và các bạn sẽ có giá của căn nhà
đúng không? Price
đúng không? Price đúng không? Giá của
căn nhà giá là một cái số gì đấy? Ví dụ
từ từ 0 đến 10 tỷ ví dụ như vậy đúng
không? Thôi giá thì chúng tôi không quan
tâm. Như vậy các thử nghĩ xem nhá. Bây
giờ ấy nếu các bạn muốn xây dựng một cái
mô hình AI để có thể dự đoán giá nhà
theo kiểu lập trình tường minh ấy thì có
nghĩa là các bạn sẽ phải làm phải làm
cái gì? Các bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra là từng
trường hợp có thể có của một căn nhà giá
nó là bao nhiêu. Các bạn tưởng tượng
nhá. Đếm qua một tí này. Đếm qua một tí
này. Đúng không? Diện tích căn nhà các
bạn sẽ có 91 giá trị đúng không? Từ 10
đến 100 các bạn có 91 giá trị. Mình quay
coi như là làm tròn là 90 đi. 90 nhá. Về
diện tích của nhà các bạn có 90 giá trị
khác nhau đúng không? Chưa kể là nhà mấy
phẩy mấy phẩy mét vuông không tính đúng
không? Flo có 5 là 5 này đúng không?
City có 30 được chưa? Street có 10 đúng
không? Nhân vội nhá. Nhân vội nhá. Đúng
rồi. If đấy nhân vội nhá. 90 x 5 là 4
450. 450 thêm 10 là 400. 4005 nhân 30 là
4500 nhân với 30
là gì? Là sơ qua thế này thôi là các bạn
sẽ phải chỉ ra giá của 135.000 căn nhà
khác nhau đúng không? Sơ qua thôi. Nếu
các bạn chơi theo hướng là lập trình
tướng minh á đúng không? Theo hướng AI á
đúng không? Là các bạn phải chỉ ra là
giá của 135.000 căn nhà khác nhau đúng
không? Mà chưa kể với các bạn các bạn
thấy thêm một cái trường gì đấy nhá. Các
bạn có thêm trường là các bạn có ờ có sổ
đỏ hay không nhá. Đúng không? Có thêm có
sổ đỏ đi. Sổ đỏ là các bạn phải nhân
thêm cáp hai rồi đúng không? Sổ đỏ xong
lại có vi bằng hay không đúng không? Đất
thổ cư hay không đúng không? Rồi các bạn
có tỷ nữa có gần trung tâm hay không? Có
trong ngõ hay là ngoài ngõ đúng không?
Rất nhiều thông tin nữa thì các bạn có
thể các bạn phải chỉ ra hàng tỷ cái
trường hợp khác nhau đúng không? If đến
hàng tỷ giá trị khác nhau đúng không?
Thì gần như là các bạn sẽ không thể làm
cách này được đúng không? Các bạn sẽ
không thể nào theo cái chơi theo cái lối
tường minh nếu mà cái số lượng cái tổ
hợp có thể có nó quá nhiều đúng không?
Các bạn sẽ không làm được. Đấy. Thế do
đó với lập trình không từ minh thì các
bạn chỉ có một cái bộ dữ liệu có khoảng
1000 căn nhà trong quá khứ đúng không?
Mỗi căn nhà các bạn có một cái giá nhà
các bạn đưa cho mô hình đúng không? Mô
hình nó sẽ phải tự nó tìm cái mối quan
hệ giữa đầu vào với đầu ra đúng không?
Thì đấy là cách mà machining nó hoạt
động. Và tí nữa tí nữa mình sẽ chỉ cho
các bạn là cách mà machining hoạt động.
Thật ra nó y chang cách mà con người
vậy. Con người chúng ta học như nào thì
ming nó làm y chang như vậy. Tí nữa mới
chỉ các bạn vì sao lại như thế nhá. Thì
hiện tại các bạn chỉ biết là gì? Là đấy
cái sự khác biệt giữa AI và machining
nhá. Sau này ấ khi mà người ta nói một
cái thứ gì đấy, nói một cái mô hình gì
đấy các bạn sẽ cần phải biết xem là cái
thứ mà người ta có nói này ấy nó có phải
machining không đúng không? Nói nó có
phải AI không thì quá là dễ rồi. Tại vì
là machine nó cũng là AI. Thế nhưng mà
làm sao để phân biệt giữa hai ông này nó
mới khó đúng không? AI và machine nó
khác nhau. Và các bạn tưởng tượng nhá
sau này ấ cái thứ mà người ta hay nói ấy
nhá các bể không? Cái thứ mà người ta
hay nói bây giờ ấ người ta hay nói về
agent ấy có biết nó nằm ở đâu không? Nó
nằm nó nằm một tí ở bên trong cái deep
learning này. Tức là gì? Nó conversation
ông AI merching deeping thì cái ấy nó là
một cái vòng tròn bé tí ở trong deep
learning này chứ nó không phải là cả chỗ
này đâu. Thế nhưng mà rất nhiều người
bây giờ người ta bị ảnh hưởng người ta
cứ nói về e người ta lại coi nó là người
ta cứ nói về A người ta sẽ nghĩ ngay đến
mà thật ra không phải như vậy. Elm thậm
chí là nó cũng không phải là mảng con
của AI mà nó là gì? Nó là mảng chắt của
AI đúng không? AI rồi machining. Machine
ở deepning. Deing rồi mới đến LM. LM nó
không có đại diện cho AI. Nó chỉ là một
cái mảng chat. Tức là nó là một cái ông
nó thể gọi là một cái ông một cái ông
chat nhưng mà học Harvard của AI. Thế
tức là một ông chat rất là nổi bật nhưng
mà không thể dùng nó để để đại diện cho
AI được nhá.
Rồi đấy là về machining. Thế bây giờ bên
trong machining ta lại có một cái vòng
tròn con nằm đ thỏng bên trong là về
deep learning. Deep learning là cái mảng
con nổi bật nhất của machining. Và hầu
hết các cái ứng dụng fancy cái ứng dụng
AI thú vị này các bạn thấy đều là các
cái kết quả trực tiếp từ deing. Trong
deing thì người ta sẽ dựa vào một cái
kiến trúc gọi là kiến trúc mạng neuron
hay là new network để có thể giải quyết
các cái bài toán khác nhau. Thế ờ các
cái mạng neuron nó đều có một cái đặc
điểm là gì? Là chúng có kích thước lớn
hơn rất nhiều so với các cái thuật toán
machining truyền thống. Các cái kiến
trúc cho mạng on này nó kí thức nó rất
là lớn. lớn thời ngày xưa của bọn mình
ấy là tầm vài triệu tham số, còn với các
bạn bây giờ là vài tỷ tham số. Đấy. Thế
tronging này bây giờ nó có mảng con là
đấy thì nhìn chung tất cả những thứ link
nó đều nặng, đều to, đều cồng kềnh cả.
Thế thì các cái kiến trúc cái bài các
cái mô hình tronging ấy nó giải quyết
được rất nhiều những cái bài toán mà
machine nó cũng làm được hoặc là có
những bài toán mà machine nó cũng làm
được nhưng mà kết quả nó không tốt bằng.
Thế thế nhưng mà để diing nó thực sự
hiệu quả ấ chúng ta sẽ cần phải có hai
yêu cầu. Thứ nhất là các bạn phải có rất
nhiều dữ liệu. Và thứ hai là các bạn
phải có cái phần cứng, tức là phần cứng
nó đủ lớn các bạn sẽ phải dùng GPU. Nói
về dữ liệu trước thế nào thì là nhiều
thế thì nó còn phục vụ thuộc vào nhiều
yếu tố, nó phụ thuộc vào bài toán, nó
phụ thuộc vào tính chất của dữ liệu đấy.
Nó sẽ không có một cái con số cụ thể. Ví
dụ như kiểu là trên 5000 sample thì là
nhiều hay là trên 10.000 nó không có như
vậy mà tùy vào những cái bài toán nó sẽ
có những cái con số khác nhau. Thì
[khịt mũi] sau này khi mà các bạn làm đủ
nhiều, các bạn có đủ kinh nghiệm rồi các
bạn sẽ có những nhận xét, các bạn sẽ có
những cái khả năng phân tích xem là thế
nào thì là nhiều. Còn thật ra với mình
cũng không có không có một con số cụ thể
nó phải tùy thuộc vào vào bài toán nữa,
phù thuộc vào cái bản thân cái trải
nghiệm của mình đã làm rất là lâu rồi
thì mình mới có cái khả năng đấy. Thế
thì deming ấy các bạn sẽ cần phải có rất
nhiều dữ liệu các bạn có thể hên mình
cái hiệu quả cái thứ nhất. Thứ hai là
phải có phần cứng
với các cái thuốc toán machining truyền
thống CPU là đủ. Thế nhưng với Ning các
bạn chắc chắn các bạn sẽ phải có GPU nếu
không có GPU thì gần như các bạn sẽ
không thể nào các bạn huấn luyện nổi các
cái mô hình vì không có GPU chạy CPU nó
rất là chậm đúng không? này ngoài TPU có
nhiều phiên bản khác. Ví dụ ngoài GPU nó
còn có cả TPU rồi NPU rất là nhiều cái
thứ nữa. Thế nhưng mà nhìn chung là tôi
sẽ có có cái phân cứng đặc chủng chứ
không thể nào mà xài chỉ CPU được. Đấy
thì đấy là về [khịt mũi] compion, về AI
về machining và deing đúng không? Cứ
mảng lớn, mảng con, mảng cháu, mảng
chắt.
Thế thì đấy là về bốn cái vòng tròn đầu
tiên camion, về AI, về machine, về
diing. Trước khi nói về data sence có
bạn nào câu hỏi gì không?
Có bắt nào câu hỏi gì không?
Tiếp nhá. Thế bây giờ á nói về dat thì
chúng ta sẽ nhìn sang bên phải nhá. Nói
về data cho các bạn nhìn sang bên phải.
Các bạn thấy là ở bên phải ấy det nó
không phải là một cái lĩnh vực riêng lẻ
mà nó là cái sự giao thoa của ba mảng
khác nhau. Đầu tiên là computer sense.
Việt Nam mình chia công nghệ thông tin
đó đúng không? Việt Nam mình chính là
công nghệ thông tin đó đúng không? Thứ
hai là mathematics
và thứ ba là domain knowledge. Domain
knowledge trong ba cái mảng này thì hai
cái mảng là conent và mathematic là hai
cái mảng mà các bạn sẽ được trang bị
trong quá trình các bạn đang học. Ví dụ
các bạn học khóa học này của mình hoặc
các bạn học trong trên trường đại học.
Thường trên trường đại học nó sẽ chính
xác hơn. Tại vì là thấy các bạn sẽ phải
học những cái môn như kiểu là đại số rồi
giải tích rồi xá thống kê đúng không?
Đấy là những thứ về về toán rồi những
cái môn khoa học cơ những cái môn như là
cấu trúc dữ diệu và giải thuật này rồi
cơ sở lập trình này rồi lập trình hướng
đối tượng này đúng không? Đấy là những
thứ mà các bạn sẽ được trang bị trong
quá trình các bạn đi học trên trường đại
học cao đẳng các thứ chương trình
chính quy và một phần nào đó là ở những
khoa học như thế này. Thế nhưng cái mảng
khó hơn là cái mảng domain knowledge.
Domain knowledge là những cái kiến thức
chuyên môn, ký thức chuyên ngành mà các
bạn sẽ chỉ có thể tích lũy được khi mà
các bạn đi làm ở những công ty đúng
không? Tất nhiên mình cũng có thể mình
sẽ chia sẻ cho các bạn những cái kiến
thức đó nhưng mà thực sự cái này nếu
không phải kiến thức của mình thì rất là
khó tại vì các bạn sẽ không làm các bạn
chỉ dựa vào kiến thức của người khác
được. Compion với cả mathematic là thứ
các bạn có thể học từ người khác được
nhưng domain knowledge là cái thứ mà các
bạn phải tự mình trải nghiệm, tự mình
tích lũy.
Thế thì do như này nên là một data
scientist có thể làm việc ở rất nhiều
lĩnh vực khác nhau. Các bạn có thể làm
data scientist trong lĩnh vực là banking
này. Các bạn làm data scientist trong
lĩnh vực y tế này, trong lĩnh vực tài
chính này, trong lĩnh vực quân sự này,
trong lĩnh vực giáo dục. Tại vì là các
cái mảng khác nhau nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi
cái domain knowledge thôi. Ví dụ các bạn
các bạn trong banking các bạn sẽ biết là
à trong banking của tôi có những cái bài
toán như thế nào? cái dữ liệu nào là dữ
liệu quan trọng, những thông tin nào là
thinh quan trọng hay là trong y tế thì
đâu là những bài toán quan trọng đúng
không? Đâu là cái dữ liệu quan trọng
hoặc là trong lĩnh vực giáo dục chẳng
hạn thì cái gì là cái cần tập trung đúng
không? Tức là nó chỉ khác nhau ở mỗi cái
domain knowledge thôi. Còn hai cái bảng
kia nó giống y trang nhau. Đấy thế nên
là như mình nói một data một data
scientist có thể làm việc ở nhiều mảng
khác nhau như mình. Ngày xưa mình đã
từng làm data ở trong làm trên mảng HR
rồi sau mình làm cho cả cho cái bên làm
về game mobile sau đó mình làm tiếp về
thể thao. Đấy là nó làm rất nhiều mảng
khác nhau rất là dễ dàng. nó chỉ khác
nhau mỗi cái domain knowledge thôi. Đấy.
Thế nên trong quá trình các bạn đi học,
các bạn cố gắng tích lũy được cái kiến
thức về conversation và mathematic tại
vì đấy là thứ các bạn có thể làm trước
được đúng không? Và thật ra ấy các cái
các cái data sent mảng khác nhau ấ nó
chỉ khác nhau đúng cái domain knowledge
thôi. Còn hai cái mảng kia cái base là
như nhau cả. Tại vì đều biết kiến thức
về com đều biết kiến thức về toán thế
các thứ nó như nhau đúng không? Thế đấy
là về bên phải. Thế bây gi các bạn nhìn
sang cái ở hình bên trái cái sve này các
bạn thấy là gì? Cái vòng tròn về data ấy
nó không nằm lọt thỏm ở bên trong bất kỳ
một cái vòng tròn nào ở bên trái nhưng
mà nó có cái sự nhất định. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì một trong số những công việc rất
là phổ biến của data scientist là gì? Là
họ sẽ xây dựng họ huấn luyện những cái
preditive founder hay là những cái mô
hình dự đoán. Những cái mô hình dự đoán
là gì? Thôi ví dụ các bạn đưa vào thông
tin input đồ vào mô hình dự đoán xem là
doanh số doanh thu của 3 tháng tới đúng
không? Thì những cái mô hình dự đoán này
phần lớn nó sẽ những cái mô hình trong
machining và cả trong deep learning nữa.
Thế nên là một data scientist thì họ sẽ
cần phải có những kiến thức về machining
và deeping để họ có thể xây dựng, huấn
luyện, đánh giá và có thể triển khai
được các cái mô hình dự đoán. cái mình
dự đoán
và do là có cái sự tương đồng như này ấ
thế nên là có hai cái row và khi mà các
bạn đi apply job ấy cái công việc nó rất
là tương đồng nhau một là data scientist
và hai là machining engineer đặc biệt
nếu các bạn làm những ở những công ty mà
có kích thước bé ví dụ công ty kiểu
startup ấy đấy thì gần như là hai cái
đôi này cái cái cái cái tas bạn làm nó
sẽ không khác nhau là mấy ở các cái công
ty lớn có thể nó chuyên Việt hóa hơn một
chút nhưng mà công ty nhỏ thì gần như là
nó hai công việc này nó tương đương nhau
data cent về Chị anh chị nhá. Bằng chứng
là gì? Với mình ngày xưa có một cái công
ty cũ đây. Cái công ty cũ của mình
đây. Công ty cũ mình đây. Công ty này
của mình trong trong team mình đây.
Trong team mình có bốn người. Hai người
có cái job title là data scientist và
hai người là maching engineer. Nhưng mà
đây này công ty này của mình mình với
một ông nữa là machininger và hai ông
nữa là data scientist nhưng mà công việc
chả khác gì nhau cả. Công thể là
startup. Tất cả công ty mình làm từ
trước giờ đều là startup cả. Đấy ở công
ty to nó sẽ chuyên biệt hơn. Thế thật ra
thì giữa hai cái góc này thô này thật ra
nó cũng có cái s một cái sự khác hiện
nho nhỏ tức là gì? Tức là data scientist
nó sẽ thiên về cái hướng cái hướng
prototype xây dựng nguyên mẫu lý thuyết
hơn. Tức là xây dựng ờ đánh giá một cái
mô hình t ví dụ kiểu ngồi trong phòng
thí nghiệm ấy để xây dựng cái mô hình
đánh giá kh đánh giá. Thế còn cái ông
machinger nó sẽ thiên về cái mảng triển
khai hơn. Tức là khi tôi có cái mô hình
rồi làm sao tôi có thể triển khai để cho
khách hàng họ dùng được. Làm sao tôi đưa
nó lên server tôi đưa tôi nhúng nó vào
thiết bị của khách hàng được. Đấy thì
đấy là cái sự khác biệt. Thế nhưng mà sự
khác biệt này các bạn chỉ nhìn thấy rõ
ràng khi mà các bạn đi làm ở công ty lớn
thôi. Còn công ty nhỏ khi mà họ thiếu
người ấy thì gần như hai rành công việc
làm nó nó nó tương đương nhau. Một data
sách nhiệm triển khai mô hình và một
machine cũng có thể chịu trách nhiệm là
xây dựng mô hình.
Rồi ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Mình có một cái nhỏ là vừa rồi trang cái
hình bên trái việc cô nói là cái phần
LLM nó sẽ lọt thỏm trong phần deep
learning.
>> Vâng.
>> Ờ thì cái phần lọt thỏm trong Linking
này nó vẫn sẽ nằm ở mé bên phải là thuộc
data size.
>> Không không nó nó không nó không nằm
trong data không
>> à nó sẽ nó sẽ nằm phé bên trái của đấy
đúng không?
Đúng
>> không? Đúng. Vâng đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Dạ. Tất nhiên về mặt kỹ thuật người ta
cũng có thể người ta cũng có thể bây giờ
người ta cũng thể người ta sửng cái mô
hình ngôn ng lớn để người ta có thể
để giải quyết cái bài toán trong data.
Thế nhưng mà nó nằm ở trong deink thôi,
nó không nằm trong data.
>> Ok. Nó không thuộc về.
>> Dạ.
Có nào câu hỏi gì nữa không? Có ai có
cái gì các bạn chưa clear về các cái
khái ni kh này không? Rất là quan trọng
các bạn nhá. Chúng ta muốn học về dat,
chúng muốn học về machining, chúng ta
phải biết nó là cái gì đã, đúng không?
Chúng ta phải biết cái thứ chúng ta muốn
học nó là cái gì đã. Được chưa?
Và đặc biệt là sự khác biệt giữa AI và
machining nhá. Đặc biệt rất là quan
trọng.
Các bạn có khả năng phân biệt rồi. Các
bạn biết là sau này cái thứ mà người ta
nói các bạn biết là nó là cái gì? Nó là
AI hay nó là machining, đúng không? Là
AI thì trước đã là machining nhưng mà là
machining thì sẽ là AI. Tất nhiên tất
nhiên ấy lý như thế này nhưng mà theo
quy ước áo quy ước á nhá theo quy ước ấy
thông thường thì khi người ta nói là một
cái gì nó là deep learning ấy thì thường
người ta sẽ hay nói về mạng neuron còn
những cái thứ người ta nói về machining
thường người ta hay nói về cái mô hình
truyền thống cái mô hình bé bé bé bé đấy
th thông thường là là như thế thế nhưng
mà về mặt kỹ thuật thì những cái mạng
nonon nó cũng đều là machining cả tại vì
đây nó là bảng con mà đúng không
có vấn đề gì cả khi mà mình chưa có
domain knowledge thì mình vẫn có thể xây
dự được mà có vấn đề gì đâu Mình có cái
bộ dữ liệu đâu, mình có thể lấy cái bộ
dữ liệu trên mạng về mà mình xem là cái
bộ dượu này mình có thể dùng để mình xây
dựng cái mô hình dự đoán cái gì đúng
không? Nó có thể được mà các bạn không
có domain knowledge các bạn vẫn phải làm
dự dự án cá nhân được mà không có vấn đề
gì.
Gen ai nó geni nó nó thuộc về thì thì nó
chính xác hơn. Zen là một cái
e tạo sinh. E tạo sinh đúng không? Nó là
bên trong của em.
Ok.
Có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Vì sao người ta gọi là AI tạo sinh? Là a
tạo sinh vì nó có thể sinh ra được những
cái dữ liệu mới, những dữ liệu chúng ta
không lường được. Ví dụ nhá, các cái mô
hình motioning và deep learning đi đúng
không? Các cái mô hình các bạn dùng nó
để dán giá giá nhà thì các bạn biết là
gì? Giá nhà nó chỉ là giá trị từ 0 đến
10 tỷ thôi đúng không? Các bạn sử dụng
cái mô hình dự đoán xem email có phải
email spam hay không thì các bạn biết là
gì? Cái output đầu ra nó chỉ là spam hay
không thôi. Đấy là mô hình truyền thống
bình thường. Thế còn e tạo sinh ấy nó
tạo ra bức ảnh mới. Các bạn đâu biết ảnh
nó trông như nào đâu đúng không? Các bạn
sẽ không biết bức ảnh đấy nó tạo ra như
nào. Hoặc là bây gi các bạn bảo là cái
mô hình nó phải viết cho vào một cái
đoạn đoạn văn đi. Các bạn đâu biết các
bạn đâu biết đoạn văn nó trông như nào
đâu đúng không? Nó sẽ sinh ra những cái
thứ mà các bạn không lường trước được.
Đấy là e tạo sinh
rồi. Ok.
>> K Việt đây.
>> Dạ.
Ờ thế thì geni thì theo em hiểu thì nó
cũng có thể sinh ảnh hoặc là sinh voice
thì
>> đúng đúng chính xác là như vậy không
phải cũng không thể gọi là con của em
được không ạ? Th b này tức là tức tức là
tức là ở bên trong ấy những cái những
cái ấy nó dùng cái elm nó là cái phần co
của nó mà cái phần nóng code là mà nóng
code là những cái m ngôn ng lớn ở bên
trong.
Các bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Chat GPT nhá.
Chat GPT là công cụ AI.
Nó được xây dựng dựa trên GPT và GPT là
mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn nhá. GPT là mô hình
ngữ lớn, nó là trái tim, nó là bộ óc.
Còn chat GPT nó là cái vỏ bọc nó dùng
cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn đấy. Đi không
vì có chat GBT mà các bạn mới có thể
tương tác dễ dàng với GBT. Chứ bình
thường ấy mỗi cái GBT này ấy các bạn
muốn tương tác nó không dễ đâu. Tại vì
sao? Cái GPT ấy cái input đồ vào người
ta phải đưa nó về dạng số hóa phải số
dán dạng vector thì GPT nó mới hiểu
được. Nhờ có chat GPT các bạn cứ tưởng
tượng này. GPT nó là một cái linh kiện ở
bên trong cái cái máy của các bạn. Bình
thường các bạn đâu có cắm thẳng dựa vào
đấy được đâu đúng không? Nhưng có CHT nó
sẽ có thêm cái phần vỏ bọc ở ngoài các
bạn có thêm chỗ cổng USB đúng không? Nhờ
đó các bạn tự áp nó dễ dàng hơn. Được
chưa? Thì khi mà nói về mô hình ngôn ngữ
lớn ấy chúng ta nói về cái về cái th
thành phần core ở bên trong của những
cái công cụ đấy chứ chúng ta không nói
với cả công cụ. Ví dụ ví dụ nhá.
Ví dụ như là đấy ví dụ như chat GPT đấy
đúng không? Chat GPT là nó ở bên trong
nó có con GPT GPT 4 GPT5. Thế cái đấy là
mới là ngôn ngữ lớn. Còn chat GPT nó chỉ
là công cụ AI thôi đúng không? hoặc là
hoặc là mấy cái kiến trúc mấy cái mô
hình à mấy cái mô hình mấy cái mô hình
đây này các bạn dùng close nhá các bạn
dùng close nhá đây nhá
ví dụ bạn dùng close nhá các bạn nhìn
này cái close này
nó không phải nó không phải là cái gì
là cái này này
đây này
đây này đúng không? Nó là cái nó là cái
cái kho còn cái close này nó chỉ là cái
vỏ bên ngoài thôi. Nó chỉ công cụ bên
ngoài thôi đúng không? Các bạn sẽ không
tho các bạn có thể tự nhiên các bạn
tương tác các bạn sờ mó được vào mấy ông
zet vus này nhưng mà nhờ có close các
bạn mới tương tác được với chung đúng
không? Đấy
còn việc vậy thì trong đấy thì khái niệm
gen AI thì nó sẽ nằm ở chỗ nào? Ví dụ
như close và những cái model hoặc là cái
set và
>> đây đây đâ đâ đấy nó nó nó chính là gen
vâng chính là nó đấy chính là nó
>> là cái model này chứ gì
>> vâng là là nó đấy đúng rồi gen này hoặc
là nó chính là ngày xưa chúng ta có mid
j đấyy đấy nó gen nó sinh được văn bản
sinh được nhạc sinh được ảnh sinh được
video đây gen gen gen là cái đấy đấy
generative ai tạo sinh đấy
>> có nghĩa là nó là cái giống như ở đây là
cái opus 46 và cái sonet
>> vâng vâng đấy vâng Vâng. Ai đúng không?
>> Ờ không không đây. Cái này tức là cái
này nó là cái này nó là đúng không?
Vâng. Còn bọc cả cái close này rồi thì
nó mới là nó mới là geni.
Bọc cái clot nó mới là geni.
Anyway. Anyway. Thông thường thì khi mọi
người làm việc các bạn khi mà các bạn
nói chuyện với những người bình thường
ngoài ngành ấ các bạn cũng không cần
phải tức là ý ý mình là theo kinh nghiệm
mình các bạn cũng không cần phải là ờ
gọi là ờ tranh cãi là tranh lòng được vì
cái sự khá nghiệm đấy. Tại vì là rất là
khó những người ngoài ảnh họ có thể hiểu
đ được cái điều đu đấy. Nhưng mà mình ch
muốn với các bạn là gì? là chúng ta đang
người là những người chúng ta học AI à
theo hướng là truyền thống thì chúng ta
sẽ cần phải phân biệt được cái sự khác
biệt giữa chúng đúng không? Mỗi một cái
nó sẽ có những cái riêng. Cái thông
thường khi bạn ở ngoài nhiều khi người
ta gọi không đúng. Thế nhưng mà các bạn
học thì các bạn cần phải biết được xem
là chúng nó khác nhau như thế nào nhá.
Rồi ok chúng ta tiếp nhá. Chết rồi chơ
một xíu
rồi. Ok tiếp nhá. Thế bây giờ các bạn
nhìn này. Thế vừa nãy các bạn nhớ không?
Mình vừa nói là gì? Là cách mà machine
hoạt động ấy nó giống y trang cách con
người hoạt động. Thì các bạn nhìn nhá,
ngày sửa ngày xưa các bạn nhìn này, trên
cái hình này đây chính là cách mà
chúng ta ngày xưa chúng ta học đó đúng
không? Hàng ngày các bạn là đây các bạn
đây này các bạn đây này. Các bạn đây này
đúng không? Các bạn đây đúng không? Hàng
ngày các bạn sẽ được cô cho bài tập được
chưa? Các bạn làm bài tập các bạn làm ra
cái bài làm này đúng không? Cô giáo giáo
viên á sẽ so sánh cái bài làm của các
bạn.
với cả cái đáp án cái bài đáp án có sẵn
đúng không để so sánh xem là bài làm bạn
nó đúng nó khớp v đáp án đến mức nào
đúng không và cô sẽ có cái kết quả nó có
thể là bài chữa đúng không bài chữa là
bao gồm điểm với cả những cái lỗi sai mà
cô chữa cho các bạn đúng không sau đó
thì các bạn sẽ cầm cái bài chữa này để
các bạn quay ngược lại đểm làm gì các
bạn cầm bản thân đúng không và cái quá
trình này nó cứ lắp đi lại như vậy đúng
không các bạn làm bài cô chấm cái bài đó
cô ra cái bài chữa các bạn dùng cái bài
chữa các bạn nhìn vào cái bài chữa của
cô để các bạn cập nhật bản thân để làm
sao ngày mai các bạn sẽ làm tốt hơn đúng
không cứ mỗi một ngày các bạn sẽ làm tốt
hơn phiên bản của các bạn hôm trước Đúng
không? Thì đây là cách mà các bạn học
đúng không? Thì cách mà chúng ta học
ngày xưa như thế này đúng không? Thì
cách mà các cái mô hình cho machine học
nó cũng giống y nó chả khác gì cả. Các
bạn nhìn nhá. Trong machining ấy thì máy
học bằng cách nào? Chúng ta đưa dữ liệu
vào mô hình đúng không? Chúng ta đưa
thông tin về một cái danh ngân hàng,
chúng đưa thông tin về một cái về một
cái email, chúng ta đưa thông tin về một
cái gì đấy. Mô hình nó sẽ phải đưa một
cái dự đoán. Sau đó cái dự án này của mô
hình sẽ được so sánh cái giá trị thực tế
qua một cái hàm người ta gọi là hàm mất
má hay là lost function. Thế và sau khi
chúng ta có cái L function này nó sẽ so
sánh giữ dự đoán với thực tế để nó ra
được một cái giá trị được gọi là giá trị
mất mát hay là lost value. Cái lost
value này ấ nó tương đương với cái kết
quả mà cố chấm cho các bạn và cái lost
value này nó sẽ quay ngược lại nó update
mô hình để làm sao mô hình càng ngày nó
càng tốt hơn. Đấy thì cách mà máy v học
nó không khác gì con người. N các bạn cứ
nghĩ mà xem cái cách mà các bạn học ngày
xưa ấy chính là một kiểu lập trình không
tường minh. Cách mà chúng ta học ngày
xưa chính là một kiểu lập trình không
từng minh. Tại vì vì sao các bạn tưởng
tượng nhá ví dụ ngày xưa lớp 12 các bạn
học cách tính đạo hàm tích phân đúng
không? Hàng ngày các bạn có thể làm một
các trong cả cái quá trình các bạn học
trong suốt 1 2 năm trời các bạn có thể
làm 1000 hay các bạn làm 10 bài đ 10.000
bài đào bằng tích phân đúng không? Các
bạn có thể làm 10.000 câu nhưng mà cái
hôm các bạn đi ngồi ở phòng thi tốt
nghiệp phổ thông ấy đúng không? Cái câu
hỏi về đạo tích phân trong cái hôm đấy
nó sẽ không giống hoàn toàn 100% với bất
kỳ câu nào mà các bạn đã từng làm đúng
không? Có thể trong quá trình học các
bạn là 10.000 câu đạo hàm nhưng cái câu
đạo hàm mà các bạn gặp cái hôm hôm thi ý
nó sẽ không giống một nó sẽ không giống
hoàn toàn với bất kỳ câu nào các bạn
từng làm nhưng các bạn vẫn làm được. Tại
vì sao? Tại vì các bạn đã học học đã học
cái dạng đấy rồi đúng không? Các bạn
chưa gặp câu giống y hiền nhưng các bạn
đã gặp gặp những câu tương tự rồi thì ý
tưởng của mering nó cũng như thế đúng
không? Các bạn sẽ không thể nào các bạn
chỉ ra được cho một cái mô hình giá của
1 tỷ căn nhà khác nhau đúng không? Không
thể các bạn chỉ ra được các bạn chỉ nó
khoảng 1000 căn thôi. Nhưng mà nhờ cái
quá trình nó học căn này nó sẽ có thể
sau này nó sẽ dự án được những cái thứ
mà nó chưa gặp bao giờ đúng không? Trên
thế giới này nó có vài tỷ câu đạo hàm
làm sao các bạn học hết được đúng không?
Các bạn chỉ học được vài nghìn à vài vài
nghìn vài vài vài chục nghìn câu là căng
rồi đúng không? Nhưng mà không đi thi
các bạn vẫn làm được. Tại vì sao? Các
bạn đã học được cái cách để làm sao để
tôi có thể dựa vào đầu bài tôi ra được
cái output rồi đúng không? Thì con người
học thế nào thì machine nó học y trang
như thế nó không khác gì cả. Thế nên nếu
mà các bạn trong quá trình các bạn học
về AI, các học về machine ấy mà các bạn
có được cái cách hình dung, các bạn có
cách là gọi là so sánh matching giữa
cách con người học với cách máy học ấ
thì các bạn thấy nó rất là giống nhau
luôn, rất là tương tự nhau luôn đúng
không? Con người chúng ta ngày xưa chúng
ta học cũng là một kiểu học không tường
minh.
Các bạn có thử nghĩ xem ngày xưa lúc mà
các bạn đi thi tốt kệp chuộc phổ thông
làm gì có ai được gặp cái đề giống y
chang ngày xưa các bạn học đâu đúng
không? Không thể giống y trang được.
Kiểu gì nó phải khác đi một tí đúng
không? Lúc học là đạo hàm của x mũ 3, đi
thi đạo hàm của x mũ 4 chẳng hạn đúng
không? Nó sẽ không giống hoàn toàn nhưng
các bạn vẫn làm được đúng không?
Merchining nó cũng theo cái ý tưởng đó.
Rồi
có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào? Đây hai thì này nó tương
đương nhau các bạn nhá. Các bạn chính là
cái mô hình được chưa? Các bạn chính là
cái mô hình bài tập chính là dữ liệu. Và
các bạn thấy không? Muốn tạo ra một
người học sinh giỏi dựa vào rất nhiều
yếu tố đúng không? Thứ nhất là bản thân
cái tư chất của học sinh nó phải tốt
đúng không? Bản thân cái tư chất của học
sinh nó phải tốt. Tức là gì? Bản thân mô
hình nó đã phải tốt rồi. Thứ hai là gì?
Cái cái đứa học sinh nó thông minh là
một chuyện nhưng mà cái dữ liệu đưa vào
nó cũng phải phù hợp đúng không? Muốn
dạy nó làm cái gì thì phải đưa dữ liệu
đúng về cái đấy làm đúng không? Muốn dạy
nó làm toán mà lại đưa bài tập về vật lý
chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ không thể làm toán
được đúng không? Bài tập nó và nó phải
tốt đúng không? Bài tập tốt đúng không?
Và bài tập tốt rồi cái gì nữa? Cái đáp
án nó cũng phải đúng đúng không? Bây giờ
bài tập mà tốt đi nhưng mà đáp án sai
đúng không? Cái câu này làm đã nh phải
phải ra sáu đi các bạn. Lại đáp án lại
ra bốn chẳng hạn thì cũng hỏng đúng
không? Đáp án cũng phải tốt đúng không?
Mà đáp án phải tốt rồi thì cái việc mà
các bạn so sánh giữa bài làm với đáp án
nó cũng phải tốt luôn. Tức là cái ông
giáo viên nó cũng phải tốt đúng không?
Chứ còn bây giờ bài làm à dự đoán về
thực tế nó tốt rồi mà cái hàm mất mát nó
sai chẳng hạn thì tôi cũng không thể tôi
ra được cái mô hình tốt được.
Không cái cái đấy là cái khái niệm mà
chúng ta sẽ liên quan đến việc là chúng
ta ví dụ là chúng ta file to những nguồn
ngôn ngữ lớn các bạn nhá. Cái đấy thì
mer chuyển động nó không nó chưa đến đấy
đâu. Tức là gì? Bây giờ thay vì tôi phải
huện những cái mô hình cồng kềnh tôi sẽ
huấn lệ những cái mô hình nhỏ hơn dựa
trên cái chỉ dẫn của cái mô hình cồng
kềnh đó. Đ thì đấy là cái kiểu mà mô
hình cha mô hình con. Nhưng mà trong cái
này các bạn chưa học đến đấy đấy đâu
nhá. Đấy là về rồi nhá.
Rồi có bác nào câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Đấy cách mà machining, cách mà máy học
nó tương tự cách người học. Chúng ta học
nào máy nó y chang như thế đúng không?
Thế đúng không? Dữ liệu phải tốt, cái
hàm mất mát cũng phải tốt đúng không? Và
bản thân cái mô hình nó cũng phải tốt
nữa. Rất nhiều yếu tố
khác các bạn ạ. AI nó khác. Enentic AI
là theo kiểu nó là tức là nó sẽ sử dụng
nhiều cái AI agent để nó có thể làm
những tác vụ khác nhau. Nhưng mà thế lại
nói về agent rồi. Aent là kiểu
AI mà nó có thể nó thực hiện chủ động
các cái tác vụ như là gửi mail tìm kiếm
thông tin kiểu kiểu như vậy nhá. Thì nó
sẽ cái level nó cao hơn nó có thể nó
điều phối giữa các cái agent. Đấy.
Rồi
tiếp nhá.
Rồi thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói về data.
Data là một thứ cực kỳ quan trọng trong
AI nhưng mà khốn nỗi các cái khoa học về
AI thì thường người ta lại hay nói về mô
hình nhiều. Cái khoa học về AI người ta
nói rất nhiều về mô hình thực sự ấy cái
thứ mà sao các bạn sẽ tốn nhiều hơn
không phải là mô hình chắc chắn luôn là
dữ liệu. Suốt có thời gian mình đi làm
từ trước đến giờ ấy ra ph lớn mình làm
việc là cùng với dữ liệu chứ không phải
là mô hình. Đấy thì chúng ta sẽ nói về
dữ liệu. Dữ liệu trong AI. Dữ liệu trong
ai thì môn hình vạn trạng trong đó thì
có một vài cái kiểu chính. Đầu tiên là
dữ liệu dạng bản,
thứ hai là dữ liệu dạng văn bản. Thứ ba
là dữ liệu dạng hình ảnh bao gồm cả
video luôn anh nhá. Hình ảnh bao gồm cả
video luôn. Và thứ tư là dữ liệu dạng âm
thanh. Thì đây sẽ cái loại mà chúng ta
phổ biến nhất chúng ta sẽ hay gặp. Trong
cái khóa này các bạn sẽ chủ yếu làm việc
với dữ liệu dạng bảng là cái loại phổ
biến nhất. Các bạn chú ý nhá. Với những
bạn nào mà các bạn muốn trở thành một
data scientist thì phần lớn thời gian
các bạn sẽ làm việc với rượu giặc bạc
như thế này.
Thế còn bạn nào mà các bạn ví dụ các bạn
đi show vào bảng capital vision giống
như mình thì các bạn sẽ thành ph lớn ra
các bạn làm việc với ảnh với video. Bạn
nào các bạn thêm bảng LP các bạn sẽ làm
việc với text với văn bản. Còn có cái
bảng audio nữa thôi. Mảng audio thì mình
sẽ nói sau. Được chưa? Thế rượu giặc bà
các bạn chú ý này, trong bốn cái kiểu
rượu này ấ thì rượu giặc bà là cái kiểu
duy nhất được xếp vào loại là structure
data là dữ liệu có cấu trúc nhá.
Structure data là dữ liệu có cấu trúc.
Thế còn ba ông kia đều là dữ liệu phi
cấu trúc hay là unstructure data. Được
chưa? Dương dạng bảng thì thường nó sẽ
có hai cái định dạng phổ biến là file
Excel và file CSV. Được chưa? Dạ bảng
người ta gọi là tabul data. Tabul data
để mình viết cho các bạn nhá. Tabul data
là rượu dạng bà. Đó là rượu có cấu trúc.
Đây cấu trúc đây. Cấu trúc đây. Hàng cột
từ minh rõ ràng được chưa? Thế đây là
một cái ví dụ về một cái dữ liệu dạng
bài đúng không? Đây là cái dữ liệu mà
các bạn nào các bạn muốn chuyển
datacentis sẽ làm việc rất là thường
xuyên với nó. Và hầu hết quá này chúng
ta sẽ làm việc với kiểu như này. Được
chưa? Tiếp theo là dữ liệu dạng
văn bản, dạng document, dạng text. Trong
khóa này chúng ta cũng sẽ có một cái
project chúng ta sẽ làm việc với rượu
kiểu như này được chưa? Thế cái rượu này
có thể hình thức nó nó vẫn là bảng thế
nhưng mà nó sẽ có những cái đoạn tex dài
đúng không? Nó ch đạn tex dài nó mang
nghĩa là văn xuôi. Đấy ví dụ đây là một
cái ờ một cái file rượu về về job chẳng
hạn đúng không? Thì đây là rượu dạng văn
bản đúng không? Vậy nó khác là gì? Nó
khác là ở đây nó bao gồm cả những cái
đoạn tch dài. Nó bao gồm cả những cái
thứ liên quan đến ngôn ngữ đúng không?
Thì đây là dữ liệu dạng văn bản
đúng không? Trong trường hợp này thì nó
có thể gọi là dự có cấu trúc nhưng mà
nhìn chung là văn bản sẽ dự phi cấu
trúc. Tức là nói về từng trường một. Ví
dụ nói về cái trường description này nó
sẽ là phi cấu trúc. Thì nó là tex nó nó
có cấu trúc gì đâu. Cấu trúc là phải như
này đúng không? Mỗi một sample có cùng
số lượng phần tử như này. Thì đấy phải
có cấu trúc. Thế tiếp theo là dạng ảnh.
Dạ ảnh đây là cái dữ liệu phổ biến đây
là cái dữ liệu mà mình chủ yếu làm việc
cùng. Chủ yếu làm việc cùng thật ra thật
ra với mình thì mình thích dạy về cái
lớp sau lớp này là lớp deing for
computer vision hơn. Vì dư ảnh sẽ thú vị
hơn rất là nhiều. Thế nhưng mà muốn học
về deep learning các bạn phải có kiến
thức nền tảng về machining đã. Bao giờ
cũng sẽ phải học về machining trước rồi
mới học về deep learning. Đấy d ảnh với
video như này đúng không? Nó có cái yếu
tố thị giác rất là mạnh mẽ. Và cuối cùng
là dữ liệu dạng audio nhưng mà cái mảng
audio này các bạn sẽ ít đi gặp hơn. Các
bạn sẽ ít thích khi gặp cái mảng này hơn
nhá. Audio. Đấy bốn cái dạng cơ bản được
chưa? Khóa này chúng ta sẽ chủ yếu cho
tập trung vào cái rượu dạng bảng như thế
này nhá. Rượu có cấu trúc sa data. Đấy
rồi có bào câu hỏi gì không? Đến đây có
ai có câu hỏi được không?
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Ờ
gì á thường các cái rượu lưu trữ trên my
trên trên MyScale là Scale server nó
cũng dạng bảng nhá. Đấy chính là một đấy
riêng về cái quỷ scale chính là dạng
bảng đấy chính là ví dụ của bảng đấy
mình chuyên về captivation thôi.
Ờ cái hồi mà ngày xưa mình chuyên môn
của mình khi mình được học ở The Monic
là về Covation nhưng mà khoảng 3 năm đầu
tiên mình ra trường mình làm về NP sorry
khoảng 5 năm vừa rồi mình làm về C
commisation
rồi
commentation hay lắm bạn nào mà các bạn
sống sót đến khóa sau các bạn học com
các bạn thấy rất nhiều cái th quý vị nhá
là ảnh thích lắm
tiếp nhá tiếp nhá
làm sao mà đưa được làm sao mà đưa được
văn bản gì không ông thật ra thì sẽ có
cách bước là bước tiền xử lý bước tiền
xử lý để đưa về nhưng mà người ta sẽ
đúng không văn mạc bạn ông ông dài ông
ngắn ông to ông ông nhiều ông ít làm sao
mà đưa về cùng một kiểu được đúng không
trừ phi là số hóa nó nhưng mà một khi đã
số hóa rồi thì người ta sẽ không coi đây
là rượu gốc nữa khi mà đã số hóa rồi nó
người ta sẽ coi là rượu đã qua tiền xử
lý rồi để đưa vào mô hình ta sẽ không
coi nó là dữ liệu gốc nữa đấy người ta
gọi là cấu trúc hay phi cấu trúc là ta
sẽ dựa vào cái dữ liệu gốc của nó đúng
không cái dạng này thì vẫn là có cấu
trúc Nhưng mà cái trường description này
nó sẽ là phi cấu trúc đúng không? Tại vì
trường này có ông dài ngắn khác nhau mà
đúng không?
Rồi nhá. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ
trong cái khóa này chúng ta sẽ khi mà
chúng ta làm việc ví dữ d liệu dạng dạng
tex này ấ thì mình sẽ lấy cho các bạn
cái bộ dữ liệu mà ngày xưa ở công ty cũ
của mình. Cái công ty mình hồi là mình
còn làm sinh viên ấy, mình làm working
student. Mình làm về cái hiệu này thì
các bạn thấy là cái private data nó khác
với public data như nào? Public data thì
thường nó đã clean rồi, còn private data
là các bạn sẽ phải tự clean.
Rồi
có ai có câu hỏi gì không? Ai có hỏi gì
nữa không?
Có mình sẽ phải xử lý đúng không? Có cái
có empty sale, có cái trường bị khuyết
đúng không? Có missing data mình sẽ phải
xử lý đúng không? Xử lý nào thì ở phần
sau nhá. Phần sau.
Rồi tiếp nhá. Thì bây giờ chúng ta hãy
nói sâu hơn một chút về đi. Về dữ liệu
đi. Dữ liệu chung chung nhá. Khi mà nói
về dữ liệu ấy thì nó sẽ có hai loại. Một
là unlabel data và hai là label data.
Thì các bạn nhìn nhá, dữ liệu xung quanh
chúng ta rất nhiều. Các bạn chat với
nhau trên mạng nhưng cái đoạn chat đấy
nó là dữ liệu. Các bạn đi mua đồ ở SK
hoặc là Vinmax ấy, cái hóa đơn các bạn
nhận về cũng là dữ liệu. Mình nói chuyện
với các đoạn này mà cái đoạn ghi âm này
được được ghi lại ấ nó cũng là dữ liệu.
Các bạn chụp ảnh nó cũng là dữ liệu. Các
bạn thở nó cũng là dữ liệu đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà hầu hết dữ liệu chung quanh
chúng ta đều ở cái dạng là unlable data
tức là rượ liệu không được nhãn. Tức là
chúng ta sẽ không biết là cái dựa đấy nó
là về cái gì đấy đúng không? Chúng ta
chỉ có một cái chúng ta có có cái dựa
đấy nhưng chúng tôi không biết là nó về
cái gì. Thế bây giờ ấy nếu mà có một
người nào đấy người ta ngồi người ta
đánh nhãn dữ liệu, đánh nhãn là gì? Tức
là ví dụ như này nhá. Ví dụ bây giờ có
một người người ta ngồi người ta xem
những cái đoạn người ta tập hợp cái bài
báo người ta đánh nhãn là gì? là cái bài
báo đầu tiên là về chủ đề văn hóa, bài
vàáo thứ hai là về chủ đề thể thao, bài
nữa là về chủ đề chính trị, bài nữa là
về chủ đề giáo dục chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như
vậy thì quá trình này ta gọi đánh nhãn
dữ liệu, ta gọi là data annotation hay
là data labeling. Quá trình đánh nhãn dữ
liệu thì quá trình đánh nhãn dữ liệu này
sẽ biến dữ liệu không được đánh nhãn
thành dữ liệu được đánh nhãn. Dữ liệu
không được đánh nhãn thì thường bừa phứa
ở ngoài còn dữ liệu được đánh nhan ít
hơn rất là nhiều. Dự liệu được đưa đánh
nhãn được đánh nhan ít hơn, khan hiếm
hơn, quý hơn tốn kém hơn. Tại vì là cần
phải có người động vào mà đúng không?
Thì các bạn đóng bên trái là ví dụ của
rượu không được đánh nhãn còn bên phải
là rượu được đánh nhãn đúng không? Bên
trái các bạn chỉ biết là đây là hình
thành hình con gì đấy nhưng mà còn nếu
là con gì các bạn không biết đúng không?
Con đầu tiên là con gì không ai biết.
Con thứ hai là con gì cũng không ai
biết. Cái đoạn tex này là về cái gì cũng
không ai biết đúng không? Thì bây giờ có
ai người ta đánh nhãn người ta đánh nhãn
là đây là con mèo, đây là con thỏ và đây
là chủ đoạn tch về chủ thể thao chẳng
hạn. Thì đây chính là thành rượu có đánh
nhãn. Xung quanh chúng ta quá 99% là
rượu là không được đánh nhãn. Dưới 1% là
rượu được đánh nhãn. Nó rất là ít, rất
là khan hiếm và nó cũng rất là quý hiếm.
Ở Việt Nam thì cái job về data adotation
rất là mở rộng, rất là phát triển. Rất
là nhiều công ty làm về cái mảng này tại
vì chi phí nhân công nó rẻ. Đấy, cái
bước này nó rất là nhàm chán nhưng nó
rất là quan trọng. Tại vì là nếu mà
không có dữ liệu để nhãn chất lượng ấy
thì các bạn cũng sẽ không thể các bạn có
cái mô hình chất lượng được. Đấy.
Ừ. Bạn hỏi đi.
Ở cái dữ nhiệm đánh giãn này thì tại sao
mình không nghĩ đến cách là mình dùng AI
mình đánh nhãn cho nó hay.
>> Tại sao mình cứ phải dùng con người
>> thế này nhá. Thời ngày xưa ấy khi mà nó
chưa phát triển ấy thì
tất con người phải làm tất cả rồi. Còn
bây giờ người ta hoàn toàn có thể dùng
AI để làm một công việc ta đo là free
annotation hay là tiền đánh nhãn nhá.
Chúng ta hoàn toàn có thể dùng AI để
tiền đánh nhãn. Thế nhưng cái rượu có
đánh nhãn này ấ nó chỉ được coi là rượu
hợp lệ khi nào? Khi mà có bàn tay của
con người can thiệp vào. Tức là gì? Tức
là có thể dùng AI để tiến hành nhãn
nhưng phải có con người ngồi kiểm tra,
check và sửa lại nếu cần. Chứ còn nếu mà
chỉ dùng AI để đánh nhạn ấy người ta sẽ
không coi đấy là label data nhá. Bao giờ
cũng phải có con người can thiệp không
tự đánh nhãn thì phải có ngồi kiểm tra
chứ không thể nào mà chỉ dùng cái công
ai làm từ đầu đến cuối được. Đấy tất
nhiên mình
>> vẫn phải có luật. Có luật là phải vẫn
phải có con người vào các
>> vẫn phải có con người. Vẫn phải con
người. Chính xác vẫn phải
>> mới là dữ liệu đánh nhãn hợp lệnh.
>> Đúng [hắng giọng] rồi. Tất nhiên chúng
ta hoàn toàn chúng ta có thể dùng công
cụ AI để đánh cho tiền đánh nhãn. Chúng
ta đánh nhãn nhiều đánh nhãn 10.000 S
thì không có ai người ta kiểm tra cả.
Các bạn có thể các bạn bảo với người ta
không ai người ta phát hiện ra nhưng
rượu và nhãn nó chỉ hợp lệ khi mà có con
người can thiệp thôi. Còn không có con
người can thiệp thì không có giống như
kiểu này. Giống như kiểu là bây giờ bây
giờ mình đi lại trên trường mình hoàn
toàn mình có thể nhờ một bạn sinh viên
năm cuối giúp mình soạn đề cương đúng
không? Mình chả phải làm gì cả bạn ấy
làm hết. Thế nhưng đến cuối mình vẫn
phải chốt lại, mình vẫn phải già soát
lại xem có cái vấn đề vấn đề gì không
chứ mình không thể nào mình đem nguyên
cái đề cương báy soạn để làm cái đề
cương trình chính thức mà mình không có
sửa đổi gì đúng không? Nên nó cũng giống
như kiểu dùng AI ấy đúng không? Kiểu gì
cũng phải có con người can thiệp. Mà vì
là có con người can thiệp thế nên là cái
rượu có đánh nhãn nó mới đắt chứ còn nếu
mà dùng ai mà chết hết được hết thì nó
đã rẻ rồi.
Đúng rồi. Chúng ta
>> có nghĩa là khi mà có con người mà con
người người ta đã xác nhận là dữ liệu
hợp lý mà mang cái dữ liệu đánh nhãn này
đi mang đi bán thì cái bên mua thì họ có
phải check lại một lần nữa không? Hay là
họ cũng
>> đ tùy đ tùy sự tin tưởng. Ví dụ như là
thường thường là lúc ban đầu người ta
vẫn phải check. Tại vì lúc ban đầu khi
mà hai bên chưa biết gì về nhau cả một k
hợp đồng thì vẫn phải check. Công ty của
em ngày xưa cũng phải đi check như vậy.
Nhưng mà sau khoảng 1 2 tháng check thấy
họ làm rất là tốt rồi mình sẽ không kiểm
tra nữa. Thế thường các cái công ty là
về đánh nhãn rượu họ sẽ có một cái bên
là họ có cái cái là QA tức là không phải
là question and answer đâu. Nó là
quality assurance tức là đảm bảo chất
lượng. Tức là họ sẽ kiểm đánh họ sẽ kiểm
tra ngẫu nhiên một cái lượng phần trăm
dữ liệu hỏi xem là có tốt hay không.
Thừa có công ty đánh nha dữ liệu họ phải
có cái bảng đấy rồi. Tất nhiên là khi mà
đưa dữ liệu cho mình mình cũng nên kiểm
tra lại nhưng mà khi mà hai bên có sự
tin tưởng rồi thì họ sẽ không kiểm tra
này nữa.
>> Ok. Ông thấy mấy không? Đúng rồi. Đúng
rồi. Thiên này nhắn diệu đấy. Em thấy
mấy ông mở mười mấy nhấy. Nhìn cái này
đúng rồi. Không anh chính là đây này.
Nhãn hiệu nhưng mà mình không có access
công ty. Tức là như này đây nhá. Kiểu
như này này. Ờ
đây như kiểu như này này.
Àation
nhá.
Kiểu như này này. Đấy. Thế này gọi là
cái thế này gọi là đánh nhãn này. Đâu
rồi?
Đây nhá các bạn nhìn đánh nhắc như này
này. Đâu rồi? Đây là project đây rồi.
Đây nhá. Cái cái này nó đánh nhận sẵn
rồi. Ví dụ gì đây?
Ví dụ đây nhá. Đúng không? Mình ngồi
đánh nhãn đây này. Đấy. Đây cái việc
mình ngồi mình à đây đánh nhãn này. Đây
này
một này. Được chưa?
Đúng không? Xếp này. Đấy này này. Đánh
nhãn này. Đây là đây là đánh đánh nhãn
trong camer vision của mình đấy. Như này
đấy đấy đánh nhãn đấy.
Tất nhìn vậy là nó rất là nhám chán
nhưng mà rất là quan trọng. Không có
rượu đánh nhãn tốt thì rất là khó để có
thể có những mô hình không phải khó mà
không thể có những mô hình tốt được.
Ok
đấy là về rượu của nhá. Rượu không đánh
nhãn. Có b nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Ở Việt ấy như mình thấy chỗ này đánh
nhãn nó ghi con mèo con con thỏ thì cái
vừa rồi bạn đánh nhãn là bạn chỉ khoanh
vào thôi chứ bạn không cần biết.
>> Không mày đâu. Tại vì là em để một cái
nhãn trước là kha rồi này có có một cái
nhãn
>> mặc định. Tức là nếu mà mình thấy cái
nhá này không đúng c ví dụ đây mình ghi
là v tức là em thể sẵn rồi còn nếu mà
đây không phải v mình phải chuyển lại
cat dog gì ghi vào đây. Đấy, chẳng qua
là thì lúc mà em setting này là em biết
là em chỉ đánh nhãn về xe thôi nên em để
sẵn một cái tên là xe cứ thế nó auto
thôi.
>> Đ hiểu.
>> Có chứ có chứ có mô hình mai chúng ta sẽ
học về những cái mô hình nào mà nhận
rượu là có đánh nhãn và mô hình nào nhận
rượu không đánh nhãn nhá. Đấy là phần
của mai đúng không? Phần mai chúng ta sẽ
nói là xem là cái gì hoạt động về
unlabel, cái gì hoạt động về label và
chúng ta sẽ có cái ví dụ để các bạn xem
cái sự khác biệt là gì nhá.
Đúng rồi, phải nhìn. Đúng rồi, phải nhìn
một bộ phận rất quan trọng của con người
khi đánh ra dữ liệu có hai bộ phận rất
quan trọng đó là mắt với cả tay. Mắt là
để nhìn và tay là để viết ra, đúng
không?
Rồi
thì hôm nay chúng tạm dừng đây các bạn
nhá. Mai chúng ta học tiếp nhá. Ờ tối
nay hoặ muộn nhất là mai mình sẽ tạo lên
một cái folder trên Google Drive thì
mình sẽ tất cả mọi thứ slide rồi các thứ
mình sẽ để hết lên đấy cho các bạn nhá.
Để mô hình tìm được vận thể trong ảnh
chất lượng thấp thì data mẫu đúng rồi
các bạn muốn các bạn muốn mô hình nó làm
được cái gì các bạn phải cho nó cái dữ
liệu tương tự như vậy đúng không? Muốn
mô hình dự đoán được cái gì thì đúng
không? Giống như các bạn học thế thôi.
Muốn tính được đạo hàm thì các bạn phải
học dữ liệu về bài toán về đạo hàm đúng
không? Muốn muốn tính được tích phân các
bạn phải học dựng về tích phân đúng
không? Muốn mô hình nó dựng lại cái gì
phải cho nó làm việc đúng cái kiểu dữ
liệu đấy.
Được chưa? Giống con người thôi. Đúng
giống con người xong chả khác gì cả đúng
không?
Muốn người học [hắng giọng] được lập
trình thì phải cho nó tài liệu về lập
trình chứ đúng không? Muốn người học
biết về kinh tế thì cho tài liệu về kinh
tế nhá. Đây trang như thế.
Ok.
Thế nhá. Thế mai vẫn giờ này học tiếp
các bạn nhá. Mấy buổi đầu nó về lý
thuyết nó sẽ hơi nhàm chán nó sẽ buồn
ngủ một tí bạn nhá. Sáu buổi đầu tô
khoảng ba tuần đầu nó sẽ lý thuyết thì
bao giờ nó cũng nhàm chán cũng nhàm chán
cả. Thế nhưng mà nhưng mà chúng ta cũng
phải có lý thuyết đúng không? Cũng không
thể nào mà nhảy vào luôn code được. Mình
biết là rất nhiều bạn thích code nhưng
mà chúng ta cũng phải có lý thuyết ở mức
cơ bản đã thì mới có thể code được nhá.
Ok. Cảm ơn mọi người rất là nhiều nhá.
Mai chúng học đúng giờ này các bạn nhá.
Ha.